Hello everybody, hello everybody, hello everybody, hello
everybody, welcome in!
Welcome in, hi!
Today we're finishing Alan Wake, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
I guess we're finishing the main game because there are
still the DLC, the two chapters of DLC, but we will do that
another stream.
Maybe even next week, I don't know.
Thank you for giving me a reason to check out Oshi Uplink in
Toronto this May.
Yes, I got announced!
Me and Denzatsu.dixi, we will be guests at Oshi Uplink.
Going to Canada.
Greetings, Canada.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh, Invisible Moose, thank you so much for the 50
gift and say, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thinking about going now?
Yeah, they're trying to make more VTuber conventions in
other areas.
So if you are like, man, East Coast never gets anything,
well...
Yeah!
Hello, Minto and I booze like you.
Don't get mad, I spilled paint on the floor again.
Don't get mad, please.
How does this keep happening?
I'm not mad.
I'm not even disappointed.
I'm just confused.
So, I'm just confused.
VTuberCon's everywhere.
Europe still doesn't get anything.
There's literally Vexpo.
I don't know.
I wish I could go to like Doko Min one year.
That would be really fun.
Hmm.
Yay!
DOKOMI looks so cool.
I know, right?
I want to go, I want to go.
Here are great things about DOKOMI.
Me too.
Yeah, well, you know I can only do what I'm invited to.
And what is, what is, what cons are the, are available
birthday done officially belong to unc now wait i literally
got to wish you a happy birthday yet earlier i guess
yesterday for me and now your birthday is done i'm seeing
you again as your birthday is finished unc unc unc unc
the sick beat What if it's unk?
Unk, unk, unk, unk, unk.
Unk, unk, unk.
Yeah.
Unks and hags.
I don't know.
Unk sounds so, I mean, because it's just uncle short, right?
It's just, that's what it's supposed to be, right?
Uncle shortened.
But uncle is like not inherently like an old person.
you know so i'm kind of confused where this connotation came
from or like where this you know why it's associated with
old now baby core thank you for that gift thank you oji san
localized that's what i was thinking too you can be an uncle
at one year exactly that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
an uncle since 10 years old.
Oof.
Oh my gosh.
Unk status acquired at 10.
Hey, you're born?
You're old now.
You were born yesterday?
Unk.
Oh.
Never even had a chance.
My nephew was born 10 days before me.
Unk.
My name is Alan JP and I'm a viewer excited to see more of
this game.
Oh my gosh viewer Alan JP I'm such a big fan.
I have your standee cut out in my mid cafe.
I wonder what happened to Rose.
I wonder if she's okay.
I wonder if we'll see her again.
I think so probably.
Right hopefully.
My niece was born today.
Oh my gosh congratulations.
Unk!
I grew up in Singapore.
Unk was just what we called any older man who wasn't related
to us.
Like, taxi drivers were Unkul.
I just figured the rest of the world caught on.
That's what it kind of seems like, right?
It seems nicer than being like, Hey, old man!
Hey, you, old man!
Like, hey, Uncle!
It's kind of like a friend it feels like familiar like uncle
uncle hey uncle
hey old man even like oji san i feel seems to but at the
same time i like oji san feels like you know i guess anyone
but like i feel like it's mean to like not mean but i feel
even it's like a little like it has its own connotation
right maybe like a g-chan is cuter what speak up young lady
what you said but you wouldn't call like your taxi driver
like oni san or something you know it's so i'm i'm What else
is there in Japanese to say?
Hey, vid, do a viewer.
Are you going to watch World Baseball Classic?
And what team are you going for?
I'm Team Japan because of Shohei.
You know, I don't know anything about baseball.
The only thing I know about baseball is from Power Pro.
And also, when I was a long, long time...
ago i sang the national anthem for like a major game
that's all i know but if i were to pick a team it probably
would be with otani shohei because he's on the
advertisements for the green team Itoen sponsors him like
crazy That man, you can't escape his face It's crazy
Scandal, I'm actually not an uncle But your name is Uncle
Spooky Wait, don't false advertisement Yeah, he's everywhere
in Japan He really is As soon as you get off the plane
There's advertisements of him He's everywhere
Uncle.
It's kind of crazy how, like, good he is.
Like I do, do, I guess sports do have prodigies, right?
But it's like, I guess you're an athletic prodigy.
I feel like he is that.
It's kind of insane.
generational talent for sure they definitely do oh yeah
i think it's really cute that sometimes you'll see him like
carrying like a like a hello kitty bag or something because
his wife will make him it's pretty it's pretty cute i'm an
ibu prodigy i believe that i believe that i'm old enough to
remember when Yu Darvish was the MLB player the Japanese
loved.
I don't, I've never heard that name before ever.
Is he the LeBron James of Japanese baseball?
Is LeBron James, I mean, I guess he has to be good.
I've always thought he was just a meme, though.
Imagining a young hot Onisan taxi driver.
Wait, no, I shouldn't feed ideas to fish on the novel,
right?
I'm sure they've already thought about it, to be honest.
No, what's really crazy is when you get a female taxi
driver.
I'm like, whoa!
Whoa, lady driving me!
Yeah, whoa, wow, whoa!
Because it's so rare.
I think I've only had one, like, maybe once ever.
Minto, Mr. Wake, to keep you company at work.
Good luck with work!
But at the same time, Taxis are expensive, so...
I only take them in emergencies, if it's like a...
I must get to this location.
But sometimes like if I...
Let's say, um...
Like a before 3D or something.
If I'm like, I don't want to...
I want to conserve my energy, not running from...
Train to train, then I will take a taxi, things like that.
Minto, are you awake or are you awake?
I'm a young Ibu with an unc soul.
Family raised me on the SNES and the Walkmans and VHS
because we didn't have money for the new stuff.
That's culture though.
That's culture.
Don't feel bad.
Don't be like, I think that's even better.
We need more youngins with unc souls.
SNES is an encore I owned in SNES?
Do you guys, do you say SNES or do you say SNES?
Snish.
I feel silly saying snish.
Snush.
Sush.
Snish.
Sniz.
Both.
I say Super Nintendo.
Okay, fancy pants.
Super Nintendo.
S-N-E-S.
You have room in your mouth for two more syllables.
Lucky you.
It's the full cover of it name.
I know.
Super Nintendo.
What is it?
Is it Super Nintendo Entertainment System?
S-N.
That's what I'm guessing is the last two.
That would be the full government name.
Okay, oh my gosh, I guessed that.
Super Nintendo Entertainment System.
You get your butt over here right now.
Super Nintendo, yeah.
Super Nintendo.
Slapp's mouth, this baby can fit so many syllables.
Sufami to tick off the nod weeps.
Wait.
Okay, so this is, this is, I, I, you know, I'm a, I'm a, I'm
a, I'm a young 19 forever.
But, Famicom, wait, are they different?
Wait.
Are they different?
Actually, I have no idea.
The Famicom and that.
Oh, they are.
Oh, it's S, N, wait, it's N E.
Wait, what's the NES?
Famicom is the original.
I'm such a fake fan, aren't I?
I did not have so much Nintendo.
I didn't even have a N64, so...
Before the SNES.
Super free Nintendo, or was it free Super Nintendo?
Not free.
Famicom is...
NES?
Super Famicom.
Is SNES.
Ah, okay.
CS, I always get confused.
Why can't they just like...
Why couldn't they call it the Famicom overseas too?
Right?
Confusing.
My brain.
You know what Nintendo should do?
They should go back to their roots and release cards.
Release a deck of cards again.
NES, SNES, 64 GameCube, and so on.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Famicom sounds cool.
I think so too, right?
It's like, why don't we like...
Oh, sorry, that was my controller disconnecting.
I...
We knew it wasn't a family computer.
But...
I guess that's true.
Wait.
I...
I feel like...
Sometimes, though, like...
Why don't we shorten some things similarly to how Japanese
do like aircon?
I feel like we could totally I'm always like oh, yeah, turn
on the air conditioner You know or something But I feel like
I could say aircon Instead, it's the same thing Famicom is
what Otakon would have been if he was a Ryu 2 Oh!
AC!
DC!
What does AC DC stand for?
I'm asking so I feel like I'm five years old.
I feel like I was born yesterday right now.
What's wrong with me?
We called the Famicom family down here.
SNES were almost non-existent so I never found out how we
called them.
Oh, interesting.
Alternating.
Alternating current, direct current.
Why don't we call it the...
Oh yeah, my favorite band, Alternating current, direct
current.
I'm five years old!
Insert Densetsu cord dense sticker here.
I am not afraid to ask questions, okay?
And I think everybody should also feel that way.
Otacon voice, what's wrong with AC?
Otakon was named after a U.S.
anime convention.
No, he's not.
The video game crash caused by Atari.
Families were wearing a video game, so they named it the
Nintendo Entertainment System to ease consumers.
Wait, that's so crazy.
Huh.
So there was like a bit of a story behind it.
Interesting.
ask how i see you say easy dc easy d easy is it easy d easy
oh yeah that's my favorite that's my favorite band easy
daisy oh my gosh thank you so much for the akaka that's
crazy
What?
It's even funnier how they pronounce Eminem?
How do they pronounce Eminem?
How do they pronounce Eminem then?
I can't wait.
I-Mu-Nimu?
E-M-N-M-N-M-E-M-E-M?
Everybody's giving me different answers.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I remembered yesterday.
I was talking about phones and stuff.
I just thought of this.
Because I was thinking of it earlier too.
There was a phone that I talked about yesterday.
If you didn't see the stream, that's totally okay.
But it was a phone that is like coming out that is a square
phone.
Like apparently more like phones the size of like cards and
stuff are like square cards are kind of becoming popular,
right?
And it was called the eco.
Wait...
Iko...
Iko 1 mind, I think?
But it has...
Yabloko Maloko?
Iko 1?
Iko the dolphin?
I'm gonna look it up real quick.
Iko...
one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's one.
Sorry, I just remembered it, so I wanted to talk.
I wanted, because yesterday I couldn't remember what the
name of it was, and nobody said it in chat, so I couldn't be
like, that's the one, that's the one.
Ikaam bokaam.
Ikaam.
Oh my gosh.
If you remember Ikaam, you're definitely unc.
You're VTuber unc.
Well, Junior, someone bet you breakfast?
Oh no, oh no!
I don't, I don't make the rule, sorry.
It felt like it was just yesterday, I know.
I too remember when the Wii-Hoo was invented.
Ikan, Ikan, Ikan, Ikan, Ikan, Ikan, Ikan, Ikan, Ikan.
Shall we get into Alan Wake now?
I'll quit yapping.
But I...
Wait.
Hello, controller?
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Because it's going to be a bit longer.
We're trying to get through two chapters today.
So, let's do it.
Let's get through it.
Let's wake up.
Alan, wake up!
Alan, go!
Previously on Alan Wake, under the influence of the dark
presence, I wrote a horror story.
story that is coming true yeah jagger had been my editor
making sure that the unfolding story would make her more and
more powerful some part of me had been aware enough to write
my escape into the story together we can create something
absolutely wonderful the lake everything is happening so
fast right now it makes them come true my mom gave me this
old light switch the clicker how is this going on i need to
find cynthia weaver to fix this your fault and you're gonna
pay for
that thing well we're expecting a record crowd from the
neighboring counties the clicker we hope to break the record
set by last year's love for dead isn't that a ladies and
gentlemen some people have asked me what's the big deal
about deer fest what's the deal about deer fest is
this uh this is us yeah we got arrested no oh berries cold
oh that's the last of us my bad Someone will come for it
when the time is right.
Thomas said so.
He wrote it.
The key is insurance.
It's my job to keep it safe.
Safe in the light.
Oh, it's in the light.
Phil, thank you so much for the funding you did.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
All the manuscript pages were gone.
Oh, my God.
The FBI agent had taken them.
I think my tongue just took a crap in my mouth.
How?
Wait, we're in jail now?
Uh, Al.
Al, this is not good.
Oh, Al.
Oh, nothing came out.
I am never drinking again.
Oh, Al.
I need to talk to Weaver.
She's the one in the song.
The lady of the light.
Yeah, that's right.
The lady who's obsessed with the lamps and stuff.
Whatever you say, Al, but we're stuck here.
They're not gonna...
I had some reading to do first, Sheriff.
And let me tell you, it was an interesting read.
Well, I've got you now, Raymond Chandler.
It's all here.
All the evidence, including conspiracy to murder a federal
agent.
There's no way you're walking out of here.
You hear me in there, Brett Easton Ellis?
This guy sucks.
He's so annoying.
Yeah, Alan's stuck.
Well, we all want things, Sheriff.
I wanted my...
Look, why is he freaking out like this?
Agent Nightingale, I insist.
Whoa.
Wake, what's wrong?
Lady, are you stupid?
It's a trick.
It's an obvious trick.
Okay, I've had enough of this crap.
Wake, I'm going to trust you with this.
You're joking.
Agent Nightingale, your opinion would matter more if you
were sober and if I actually believed you were here on
official business.
Oh!
Get back in the cell, Stephen King.
The only way you're leaving this place is over my dead...
Wait a minute.
I know this...
Oh my god!
He wrote about this!
Light.
We need light.
It's the only way to fight this thing.
In my office.
I've got your things there.
Follow me.
Okay.
Oh man.
We're sitting ducks with the lights out.
Stay cool.
I can get the emergency power on.
Okay, we're following.
Okay, wait, don't run so fast, please.
They're scaring me.
They're scaring me, please.
Wait, actually, are there any thermoses?
Oh, Barry is in no rush at all.
This guy is totally cruising.
Thermos!
I knew it was here.
I knew it.
Wait a second, what's our man?
Okay, the manuscript that we dropped.
Okay, so much has happened all at once all of a sudden.
Nightingale tried to make sense of the manuscript.
He didn't understand half of it.
But it all ran true.
Impossibly true.
He took out his hip flask when he reached the page that
described how he reached the page that made him take out his
hip flask.
It wasn't the booze that made his mind read.
She took out his hip flask when he reached the page that
described how he reached the page that made him take out his
hip flask.
Least lady nice to me.
I'm Alan Wake and I'm a writer.
It took out his hip flask when he reached the page that
described how he reached the page that made him take out his
hip flask.
Alan run on sentence.
Oh, oh my gosh, you guys.
There's this.
Okay, I don't know if you guys saw it, but there's this
brand called Huff, I think.
And they have a collab right now with Metal Gear.
And I saw last night before I went to bed that they were
releasing some skateboard decks.
And they looked really, really nice.
But then they also put out clothes.
And I was like, oh, these look so good.
I'm such a sucker for Yoshi Shinkawa art that I was like,
okay, I have to buy a couple shirts.
But what's really funny is on the back of them, I don't know
why this, it's because it's a funny scene.
sentence but on the back of the shirts they have like
certain quotes from the game like they're so funny because
it's like okay hold on let me just like there's like really
huge text and also just like really funny lines like there's
a gray fox shirt and it's just like on the back it's like
huge like graphic design is my passion text it says neither
enemy nor friend am back from a world where such words are
meaningless and I'm just like this is this is so awesome for
the back of my shirt look at look back at me I'm on a horse
level of writing wait I don't get it they did they had a
sticker oh I didn't see it last night dang and then there
was another one there's like a there's like a bunch I
recommend looking at the they're kind of pricey because it's
you know a it's like a special brand but they have like a
they have like a mgs2 hoodie and on the back it has like the
the human race will probably come to an end sometime and new
species may rule over this planet earth may not be forever
but we still have the responsibility to leave what traces of
life we can building the future and keeping the past alive
are one and the same thing and i'm like i want it so bad
it's so silly but i love it i know it's so good and it's
like huge text it's so awesome if i wore hoodies i would
still get it it's finally something to rival my vegeta
sitting in a throne shirt i don't know about that wait like
like a porcelain throne
nightingale felt the situation veering out of his control
but the gun at least felt steady in his hands he was ready
to fire resolved that he would let this happen over his dead
body and yet he he had seen this moment before read it in
the page he was transfixed by the deja vu and the horror
that he was a character in a story someone had written and
the monstrous presence bursting behind him and dragged him
into the night what an idiot this guy had a literal
walkthrough and still didn't realize about the the monstrous
presence the darkness coming in what a dummy he literally
had the script in him Oh my gosh.
Bear, are you good?
Sorry for the little thing about Metal Gear shirts.
It was just...
Pick up a flare.
Uh-oh.
More flares.
Uh-oh, that means I can get hurt without my police friend.
Oh, I'm on the desk.
I was like, what's this out?
I'm so glad you picked up on how much of a hack writer Alan
is.
Yeah.
Guy is silly.
Alright, let's go.
Oh.
Holy cow.
Where did she go?
In here?
The meeting room?
Oh.
Oh, geez.
She scared me.
Is this going to be like a...
Barry?
Barry, I need you over here.
Oh, okay.
I was going to say like a protect her while she turns the
lights back on kind of moment.
It says follow Sarah, but I think she's following me.
You have my stuff in your room, didn't you say?
Oh.
Okay.
It's so awkward.
Here are your things.
Wake, what do I need to know?
What do you need from me?
They can be hurt in the light, only in the light.
And I need to find Cynthia Weaver.
She can help me stop this.
It's a canon event.
Light.
Check.
Cynthia, she lives in the old decommissioned power plant.
Why?
I can get you there pretty quickly in the rescue chopper.
the chopper give me to the chopper uh okay dang all right
let's get everything oh my gosh they're like they're loaded
they're like here's your stuff and also the supplies of
every every every holy cow let's get back to your friend is
barry okay i don't feel comfortable leaving him wheeler i
need you to stay here what no we're going to fetch our ride
but i have friends who need to be warned about this and i I
can't be in two places at once.
I need your help.
Well, okay.
Here's a list of people and phone numbers.
I need you to call them and tell them you're the best
friend.
I don't feel comfortable leaving him here.
Night Springs, okay?
They'll know what to do.
Arm to the teeth.
For real.
Like the TV show?
Gotcha.
Oh, hey, that radio guy is on the list.
Main.
Who's Frank Breaker?
He related to you?
My dad.
Oh.
Hey.
Is this like a secret society?
Can you do this?
You'll be safe here.
The backup power's on.
these guys need to be alerted just in case we don't come
back uh you'll come back for me though right as soon as we
get the chopper ready thanks wheeler i owe you one the
chopper okay let's go wake through the back my hangover
wants a pizza you think there's any way i could order one
out sorry barry i gotta go
oh he's actually talking to them yeah i know great but
listen the sheriff sarah asked me to tell you something she
said says night springs okay so i guess she yes sir okay i i
see you're back there no uh she's okay she's just busy so
she asked me to wait this is so cool that you can actually
like listen to him calling the people i'm a literary agent
sir i'm just helping her out because she's busy right now
okay well the one you'd most likely be familiar with is alan
wait oh my god Okay.
Stare at him.
Oh, check it out.
Whatever took Nightingale must have broken the gate
controls.
We can't reach the gate's control box from here.
We need to get to the other side over the rooftop.
Awesome.
I'll go.
I'll open the gate for you once I'm across.
You stay here in the light and cover me, Sheriff, okay?
Are you sure?
Okay, then.
But hurry.
Oh.
Okay.
I did see okay, I remember trying to get up this ladder
before and now it's highlighted so I can still hear him say
hi Barry Wheeler
Barry Barry Barry I needed to reach the rooftop to get to
the other side of the broken gate Okay, okay Wheeler
Wheeler.
Oh.
What's the shining stuff?
Oh!
It's the doo-doo.
Oh, gosh!
I almost stepped in it!
Oh my god!
Any more of it?
Hidden around in here?
Not the doo-doo.
Yeah.
though come on oh yes I can finally use it yes let's go
do do cleansed that's a lot of birds
yeah clean it up clean it up clean it up I'm a janitor now
Alan clean that is that's terrifying there's
some more right here I think I gotta be closer.
Oh dear.
Dear Festival.
Dear Festival goes hard.
I wonder if I dropped like if I could just run around town.
Wait, I could just like reach the other side from here.
Easy peasy.
In light you can hurt them.
Yeah, we know, we know.
Lights in this game are, like, very specific, I feel.
Wait, there was a door downstairs.
Do you think I should go to it real quick?
I don't know what I think about.
Oh, I just reached the checkpoint.
I didn't get a good look at the deer.
You want to see it?
It's right there.
Why didn't he just climb the gate?
He is a rider.
He is not an ideas man.
Please understand.
There it is.
There's...
It looks even worse in the light.
Oh dear, oh dear.
I do really love how, like, the town looks in this game,
though.
Sorry, I know I'm backtracking a little bit.
I just want to make sure there's nothing that I miss in this
room over here.
Because it was lit up.
I imagine then that means we can go in there.
I just don't want to really get ambushed.
Watch.
is locked i knew it was gonna be locked oh my god okay game
i i i i get it i know your i know your tricks now hold on
alan locked what the heck i feel something tickling my arm
maybe you come back through there maybe maybe right
map in general is so beautiful.
It's like so nice looking.
I just think it's very funny that like whoa that like
they're like you're safe in the light but this game is very
bright and also like light is extremely concentrated.
Like like I'm not I'm not safe there right there but I'm
safe right there, you know what I mean?
Sequel gets much darker.
Yeah, that's what it looks like.
Just from what I've seen of screenshots.
Exciting.
Spooky.
Scary.
Oh, there's more.
Oh, it's ambushing.
Ambush me.
Come on.
Yep, up.
Nice.
All right.
Don't fall.
Alan fall.
Okay.
Now my...
I was like, I think I'm going to get ambushed here, so I
want to have my...
No coming at once!
Nice.
Okay.
jeez louise I think you can dodge the birds too that would
make sense it's okay though they give an audio cue when
they're about to like getcha getcha it's just when they all
come at once it's a little scary but we're good suddenly
birds just Alan wake things can I make that am I supposed to
climb on... No.
I'm supposed to jump?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Alan, jump.
Hey, Sheriff.
Your password.
Night Springs?
What's that all about?
It's a stupid joke we have.
That Bright Falls is the original inspiration for the TV
show.
This town can get weird at times.
Never this weird.
though i see fascinating and so the whole to bypass the
damaged control box what am i an electrician hold on oh this
thing oh bypass gate controls hold on i'm not about to get
caught in the gunk oh damn that's smart that's smart
The chopper.
Wait a second.
Madam.
Oh yeah.
Why?
Okay.
Where'd she go?
Ouch!
It's smart.
He's so stupid!
Yeah!
Oh, you missed?
Yeah.
Whoa, shoot.
Riddle!
Good job, Sheriff.
Alan Dodge.
He's so good at that.
Oh, am I still going?
I'm following you, Sarah.
That's what my objective says.
To follow you.
Ma'am.
Ma 'am.
Oh.
Okay.
Follow Sarah.
I guess we're going through.
Right?
Sarah?
I'll walk too.
I'm scared.
It's quite foggy out.
It's really a silent hill here.
Oh my god, the deer!
Oh, whoa.
Uh, light it!
Holy cow.
Ow, I tried to dodge but I was reloading at the same time!
Yeah, stay back!
Dummy.
Nice.
Boom, headshot.
That wasn't a headshot, though.
Is the deer okay?
Alan bonked.
Every time he gets bonked, he has an idea for another story.
Where is she going?
Okay.
Let's just push that into the ocean.
Sure.
Oh.
More?
She doesn't know that I have to, I have to take out their,
uh, their light, their shields first with the light.
Come on, Sarah.
I gotta take it out first.
Wait, there's gotta be a thermos around here.
Hold on, Sarah.
Is the diner open?
Oh.
Visual, visual glitch.
No way it is.
Don't I already have a heavy duty?
Oh no, I guess not.
It felt like I did.
Revolver ammo, revolver ammo.
Nice.
I don't want to go back there, though.
I'm scared.
I don't want to go back there.
Batteries.
Oh, she came in.
I'm going to want explanations, you know.
For example, what the hell happened to Rose?
She's seriously messed up now.
I don't know.
No, that's not mean.
The same thing I think happened to me after I arrived.
During this week you can't remember?
Oh, I remember now.
Oh.
I remember now.
Can we go in the kitchen?
Staff only?
Wait, we could use the jukebox still?
The lime and the coconut.
We put the lime and the coconut.
Oh.
them up both was that what was that what was that just now
was that was that an epic what was that was that an epic
games achievement
that was pretty funky anything in here sorry i love
exploring in this game it feels like There's so much I can
explore.
All right, we'll follow.
I like having Sarah on my side, though.
This is awesome.
She alerts me when guys are coming.
She's really strong.
Oh!
Holy!
Competent NPCs.
We'd love to see it.
Oh, okay, I've reached my...
Oh, 20.
I've reached my limit.
Oh, wow.
Why are they set up like this?
Oh my god!
Whoa!
And boom!
Wait, is there a guy here?
She got that guy, nice.
Oh, ow!
Oh, duh.
I was like, why isn't he not dying?
Silly Sarah doesn't know how to focus her flashlight,
obviously.
Is she in the body?
No.
Where'd she go?
There she is.
Anybody else in the body?
Sarah awake.
Sarah's strong.
Hey, Sarah.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Mate!
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Oh.
Evil?
Evil barrel?
Evil car?
Sarah?
I'm scared.
Sarah the ambiance.
It's like a zombie game all of a sudden or something, it
feels.
There's light.
There is?
Where the potty's are there for deer fest.
Oh, true, true, true.
I have a key.
Watch my back.
Oh, no, no, no.
How long does it take to unlock a gate?
Oh, shoot.
That's all I gotta ask.
Oh, no, you don't.
Oh,
she's so strong.
She's so awesome.
Okay.
with her you know what maybe I should use my shotty too yeah
yeah oh my gosh wait what is that oh what chainsaw man
chainsaws are noisy oh my gosh scared the heck out of me I'm
trying I'm trying wait yeah that's right that's right
Hello?
Ow!
I knew that was coming.
I saw it too.
Whoops!
You can kill him now!
Oh.
Oh, nice.
We got his ass.
Nice.
Yeah, he just tossed a knife at me.
They do that.
Just...
Alan wake things.
she's so awesome I love relying on her and her unlimited
ammo she has actual unlimited ammo wait there's a thermos
over here please understand my obsession
anything else wait are those flares yes three of them even
huge anything in here no I'm just breaking in entering Alan
trespass the light meant to be flickering in there oh don't
like that Alan loot you gotta wonder what all these flares
were for huh checkpoint okay someone's messed with the fuse
box here but you should be able to jury rig it while I find
the keys jury got electrocuted once today how about I look
for the keys and you get burned for a Okay.
They should be in the clerk's office on the other side of
the building near the main entrance.
That sounds really far.
Find the helicopter key.
Is it?
Isn't it Jerry rig?
She said Jerry rig.
Oh.
Jerry rig is apparently the proper way to say it, but
everyone says Jerry rig.
Oh, no way!
Is that so?
Okay.
to checkpoint.
And there's a manuscript.
Uh-oh.
It's going to say, while he's inside, about to grab the
keys, he gets the biggest ambush of his life, and it makes
him have to poo-poo his pants.
So embarrassing.
The darkness that wore Barbara Jagger's face was furious.
The story in the manuscript had been making it stronger all
the time.
It's like, Helen, why'd you write that?
She set the lighter free and heard it.
Weakened it.
It was only a matter of days before the dark presence would
be strong again.
But meanwhile, it would be difficult to recapture the
writer.
Oh.
It's like, can you imagine just him writing like the most
off, like the craziest thing?
It's just like, and then everybody realizes that the things
that he wrote were the things that are coming true.
And then they just kind of were like, Alan, why did you
write that?
Why did you, why did you write that?
It's like,
the story in the manuscript had been making it stronger all
this time but now the light had set the writer free and
heard it we can do sorry i wasn't paying attention it was
only a matter of days before okay okay uh she said on the
other side of the building hall records i'm guessing it's in
here oh moshi moshi The message was from Barry.
He was getting worried at the station.
He wanted us to hurry.
I'm worried for you too.
Don't worry, buddy.
Wait, hold on.
I do want to go upstairs, though.
The power went to his head, okay?
Clearly.
The keys aren't upstairs, wake.
I'm just going to take a quick look.
Jeez.
I'm just looking.
Can't the guy be curious?
I'm just a little curious.
And who knows?
Maybe someone moved them.
Oh, what are yous?
Night Springs!
A fusion of vigilance, conscience, and uncompromising
clarity of vision.
A need so fundamental.
iPad kid, iPad kid.
And yet, a man may be brought to his knees in a single
heartbeat.
In Night Springs.
Nice.
Yeah, get your popcorn, guys.
Oh!
For young Manny, the knight hasn't been kind.
He's a marked man.
Selected for a lifetime of certitude after answering an ad
in the newspaper.
But first, a little field surgery is required.
I bet recording these were so fun.
Wow, wow, wow.
Wow, wow.
Yeah, I think you're just about ready for it.
Just if you don't resist this kid, we gotta beat it out of
you.
What?
I don't understand.
What did I do?
I just wanted to get a job in the service industry.
Wow, you're gonna serve alright.
Go, ah, go, please!
Ooh, ah, oh god, ah!
It's coming out now.
Right between the self-esteem and the childhood traumas.
What are you doing to me?
It's Mormon.
There, I've got it.
Oh my god!
What was that?
Whoa.
Nothing for you to worry about, Manny.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
We'll tell you all about that.
Don't you worry.
Ouchie, ouchie.
You're so excited to serve.
Stranger Ant, birthed in fury and violence for the pleasure
and convenience of ruthless and malicious men.
Stranger Things.
In night springs.
Did you guys hear about how apparently the Duffer brothers,
the guys who wrote Stranger Things, were inspired by Elphin
Lead?
Oh.
Why did that fall over?
That's so scary.
Wait, why did it fall over like that?
The darkness controls the Taken.
Yeah, for the series.
Yeah, yeah.
If you think about it, if you think about it, a girl in a
lab with, like, psychokinetic kind of powers is, like,
experimented on and escapes.
And you kind of, like, it kind of makes sense.
Yeah.
That's Lucy, yeah.
It's very funny because, like, a bunch of the people that
don't like the ending of...
Oh!
My gosh.
A lot of the people that don't like the ending of the
Stranger Things show are, like, clowning on the fact that
they were inspired by the anime.
Did I get it?
I got it all?
Okay, awesome.
Surprise!
ceiling man oh he came from the roof wow sunroof they should
get that fixed yikes alright what if it rains all these
documents oh my gosh imagine the mold
and not even a good anime I heard that the manga and then
there's also because like in the anime Lucy has like a with
like a clock, a grandfather clock.
And then there's a character in Stranger Things that like
has clocks as his imagery.
But apparently it was all for nothing.
The imagery was like just because they liked the clock in
Elfin League.
Eleven's first scene is almost shot for shot.
A toned down version of Lucy's first scene.
No way!
Is it?
to be fair young girl with psychic powers escapes government
facility and finds a lover and friends to fight super demons
with is a very anime trope it very is yeah
okay now that we know this building has sunroofs oh my gosh
where'd you go where'd you go there was another guy wasn't
there or am i crazy is the one guy no the other door also
busted open oh my god oh i had my flare oh my gosh oops
well um i forgot to pick that up oh my gosh it's so dark
these flashlights are so bad.
Checking around, making sure I got it all.
Now let's go into his room too.
Oh, there's stuff.
Hunting rifle!
Wait, but I do like my pump, my shotgun.
I don't know.
I think I really like the hunting rifle too though.
I think I remember liking both.
Copy, there was...
Nice.
I can't see anything.
It's so bad.
That's what I mean.
The light in this game is so concentrated.
They're both solid.
Yeah, okay.
Of course we're going into the light that I said I did
not...
Or the room...
Why did the...
Why did that just shut?
Why did that door just shut?
On its own?
Why did it do that?
Flashbang!
They're like, get the key and then get ambushed.
Dummy.
You know what?
I will have my flashbang at the ready.
Oh gosh!
My thermost favorite streamer!
Yeah, we're getting a ton of stuff.
Oh gosh, I'm so scared.
Alright, but we have to do it.
Three, two, one, go!
Okay, Sheriff.
I got the keys.
Sheriff?
Sheriff answer me.
Leave town hall.
Oh, my gosh.
Seriously?
Wait.
Barry?
Why isn't he inside?
Oh, God.
he made it inside wake he's okay but it's dark in there we
can you know we can step around objects come on wake let's
go around we can meet him in the back we can step around we
can get around that i swear to god there's even a full like
we can pass right the logic just drives me insane because
it's so illogical wait what's that okay never mind i thought
i saw a manuscript page I see nothing.
Just doing a little bit of exploration.
No, you can't.
Absolutely, no, you can't.
You're so right.
I'm stupid.
I'm like the dummy dumb here.
There's no way we could climb over this and then...
Yeah, I'm an idiot.
I'm an idiot.
You're so right.
Whoa.
Whoa, freaky park.
What the heck is this?
I want to read it?
It's not recorded when Bright Falls was first formed as a
nameless trading post, but it became a town when the Bright
Falls mining company started to operate nearby in 1878.
It was then that Hubert Biltmore, a fur trapper, and Amos
Gunderson, a pioneer from Tacoma, decided to build a post
office, saloon, and hotel, all operating from the same
building.
Stop overestimating Alan's physical capabilities.
He's a writer, not an Olympic athlete.
You're so right.
It was through the efforts of these two men that the Bright
Falls became...
Oh, that Bright Falls became the permanent and thriving town
it is today.
Aww.
Oh.
Yellow.
Trust no one in the dark.
Okay.
Oh.
Did I see it?
Sorry.
I keep thinking.
Okay, maybe it's not just me.
I keep thinking I'm seeing things, like shining.
Watch out.
Woo!
Wait, wait, where are they?
Actually, I can't see them.
That guy is hiding behind the bench.
Nice.
It's hard to get Caesar.
I really like that they kind of organize these planned
ambushes it's never one guy at a time you know they're like
and go we can make it through the bookstore wheeler should
be waiting for us in the backyard oh hi doc i've got it
don't worry about it sarah about time somebody showed up the
shooting in the air is idiotic one of these days they'll
kill somebody and over deer fest oh deer first go back to
bed he's got a point weight look this town can't take this i
can't take this oh what about me huh what we're not gonna
take it badly he's not a very good writer so he didn't think
to write at least advantage climbing villages for himself he
said he had to make it realistic right my man has just has
no faith in himself can i go into the doctor's house
actually this place is all boarded up i don't think he lives
there oh this is the doctor's house no we can't go in either
dear fest is sacred hey oh my gosh this is so embarrassing
you guys three posts just for me oh my gosh so oh wow like
this is like when i am at an anime convention i see someone
selling like like in the artist alley selling something of
me and i'm like walk away fast walk away fast thermos hold
on i'm going to look upstairs you cannot stop me i gotta go
to the children's books better be decorated all cute for the
children's area.
It's not even.
Is there anything?
Oh.
Buy three.
Pay for two.
I thought this was a library.
Yo, Sheriff, can you deal with all the shooting outside?
I'm trying to watch a Mint Phantom stream right now.
Dog, probably.
Yeah, that guy.
They're really taking advantage of your presence here, Wake.
I heard they're selling a lot of your Alex Casey books.
right now i'm not a big fan of my own writing that's so true
wait a second we got a new minky oh why did it say minky
what's wrong with me we got a new minky am
i okay Cynthia weaver worked hard following her obsessive
rituals sometimes fighting them always giving into them in
the new binky she haunted the halls of bright falls
abandoned power plant that could only be seen by eyes that
had been touched by darkness and saved by light like she'd
been she was preparing she has been writing those things for
the war she knew would come the war between the forces of
light and darkness interesting interesting interesting no
sorry guys it'll be a it'll be a bit before my next outfit
that's the way to the chopper go to the church wait no Hold
on.
In here.
Flare gun.
Flare gun ammo.
I will reload.
And also, I will switch back to my hunting rifle.
I wish I thought for a second that there was hunting rifle
ammo.
A little sad there's not.
Can I go into his house through the backway?
Dang it!
Doctor locked his doors tight.
Alan denied.
No Alan looting tonight.
Oh, that's not good.
Thermos.
Oh, a machine.
Roblox, oof.
How's the audio, by the way, guys?
I know the...
I try...
What's it called in this game?
The voices are very quiet and the...
Um...
The voices are very quiet, but the, uh, the shooting is very
loud, so I'm sorry.
Ooh, they're giving us a lot of stuff.
Marties!
It's just me?
Is it?
Really?
Am I gonna have to defend her as she opens the church?
Is that gonna be it?
Hold on, let's make sure we got everything.
There's, like, a lot going on down here, though.
Hold on.
What's going on in the church?
We got Sunday school on Sundays.
We got Bible study on Mondays.
We got Bright Falls knitting club meetings.
Alternate Wednesday evenings.
We got Deerfest Candle Night, September 14th.
We got Deerfest Morning Service, September 15th.
What's the candle night?
So romantic.
The Presbyterian Choir of Watery Visit, September 8th, 28th.
charity bake sale October 3rd I'm coming back for the bake
sale yummies yummy yummy yummies all right I'm looking for
like manuscript pages and stuff oh huh I knew it I heckin
knew it Barry in the general store Barry got back to his
feet inside the Bright Falls general store and off.
Right next to the cans of baked beans was a locked case
filled with flare guns.
Oh, nice.
And yet here was a conveniently placed barrel of crow bars.
Nice.
Barry's smile widened as he realized that this was the
classic movie scene where the hero had to gear up and arm
himself to the teeth.
Barry threw himself into the roll.
Let's go, Barry Pro Tag!
Barry Pro Tag moment!
What does it say?
Wake and Sheriff Breaker have to meet up with Barry and then
reach the helicopter.
Okay.
Because we gotta get to the helicopter so we can get to the
Uh...
Nandake.
The power plant.
So that we can then see the lady.
That's our current objective.
Was that another?
Oh my gosh, I almost missed this flashbang.
That would have been huge!
Are we going in?
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm gonna give Pastor Howard a piece of my mind about this
lock.
I told him to get it fixed.
Ah.
Physical labor!
Uh...
What do we want to do?
Sheriff?
Oh, here they come.
Physical labor.
Oh, no, it's one of these guys.
Oh, geez.
Oh, shoot.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Uh...
I'm losing him, I'm losing him.
Oh my gosh!
I'm trying!
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
This isn't good.
Ah, nice, nice.
Woo!
Holy cow!
Survive the assault.
I'm almost out of bullets.
Uh-oh.
The bullets.
Okay, it's open.
Yeah.
That took you two seconds after you...
Focus.
Aww.
On the night before Deerfest.
All through the house.
was stirring not not even a rider
well seems kind of dangerous yeah very fire safe exactly
exactly not even a deer make it through the church that
sounds really ominous considering we're almost there we'll
have to go through the basement to get to the parking lot oh
why there's no way going through the Crypt will turn out to
be a bad idea.
That's what I'm saying.
Why are we doing that?
Why are we going through the basement?
Why is it there?
Okay.
Let's go.
Come on.
I'm scared.
Why are we down here?
What is this?
Why a red means scary.
Why is it red over there?
I need you closer.
What do you mean?
Sheriff.
Eh.
Oh!
Oh, you know what?
Throw.
Oh,
they were the big guys too.
I took care of them.
Nice.
That was perfect.
Alan Flash.
That was easy peasy.
I hear so many sound effects.
It's freaking me out.
What is this anyway?
Oh.
That's for heat, right?
Not for burning bodies?
I hope.
I sure hope so.
Is this also a crematorium?
That's what I'm saying!
Did you call 911?
Woo!
Wait, who did that?
Yes, that was the light.
Barry!
You didn't like that one?
A tough audience.
No, it was great!
I got plenty more.
What are the Christmas lights for?
Protection, man?
Like garlic against vampires?
Yeah, why would you ask that, Alan?
You stupid?
The helicopter is just across the parking lot and up the
hill.
Come on!
Let's go!
Why would you ask that?
Why are you covered in lights when these are creatures that
are weak to darkness?
I mean, to weak against light stupid what's wrong with you
Alan oh my god you're such a hater wait missing what a
missing cat Alan stupid Alan dumb Alan hater oh nice I
like how they wait for me he's got light armor exactly like
sure they're not very bright but my favorite place in the
entire world see this headlamp it's like a superpower i can
just look at one of those things and they die it's my
flaming eye of mordor nice i wish i didn't say that yeah
having a rough day at work turn youtube on see my cavioshi
playing awesome game thank you good luck with work good luck
with work good luck thanks for dropping by thanks for the
super chat I could see my house from here.
All right, hold on.
What's this?
What's this page we got going on here?
Oh, yeah, I missed two, my bad.
For it to be free, the Dark Presence needed the writer to
finish the story.
Again and again, the story let it get frustratingly close to
the writer without letting it capture him.
It was bound by the events depicted in the master.
Yeah, why didn't anyone use a headlamp until now, actually?
We could pursue the writer indirectly.
Put others on the task and stop those who would help him.
made them its puppets and sent them after Alan Wake.
That done.
Actually, you know what I would have done?
First of all, if I were buried, I would have gotten an extra
one for me.
Second of all, I mean, I know their headlamps, but if you,
like, strap them to your arms, to your legs, like, on your
butt, everywhere, all over, you could just be like a disco
ball and it would be perfect.
Oh, he said it was the last one.
Oh, okay, just kidding.
Alice had screamed until she had no voice left to scream
around her the darkness was alive oh no it was cold and wet
and malevolent and without end she was a prisoner trapped in
the dark place the tarot would have burned her mind out but
one thing made her hang on she could sense Alan in the dark
she could hear him she could see the words he was writing
his flickering shadows he sensed her too he was trying to
work his way to her oh we're gonna be running are we gonna
be in the darkness There's three pages here that we can't
get because hard mode.
We're going up, up, up to the helicopter.
It's at the top of this hill.
Why?
I mean, I don't, I get why it's on the top of the hill,
but...
Someone throws a damn school bus at your head and you're
about to take a helicopter ride with someone who may or may
not have a pilot's license.
You're cleared for departure to Night Springs.
one second everybody follow me instead real quick everyone
follow me everyone follow me oh shit oh where
that's why I needed you guys to follow me I've wasted a
bullet no it's one thing about the hunting rifle the
original version of this game there are several ads for
Verizon phones and Energizer batteries, which he used to
power your light.
The remastered game removed all the traces of the ads.
Oh, that's funny.
Timber!
Oh, geez.
Get the weight.
Oh, gosh.
Big boy.
Big boy coming in.
Ah!
Holy cow.
Anyone else?
Oh, I'm never going to get used to this.
You're okay, Barry.
You're okay.
I'm going to...
Switch to my revolver for a bit.
It's not ideal, but...
Oh, this is where the lights are!
What do you mean need a while?
It'll take too long.
I want to get out of here.
Yeah.
What's a while?
Can we get, like, a...
I feel there has to be an Alan Wake Kingdom Hearts crossover
somewhere.
I don't think that needs to be a thing.
Oh, see!
Shotgun ammo?
Oh, wait.
You know what?
We'll switch.
We'll switch to the pump action.
I think I have so much more shotgun ammo than I do anything
else, so...
Nice.
And...
Awesome.
Oh, we're about to like, we're about to fight.
We are about to fight.
Holy cow.
And I see, okay, there's these.
And there's also like the explosion barrels.
Okay, okay.
Um, why aren't you prepping?
Very, very.
Boss fight!
Whoa!
never get her back whoa oh my gosh
I think oh sorry I thought I saw one someone right there oh
my gosh
oh I didn't realize that it had my
oh wait uh shoot there we go
nice what am I Ready?
No?
Pick up the flash.
Pick up the flare.
Okay.
Where are they?
More of them?
Pick up the flare.
Okay.
Oh,
there's one.
Oh my gosh.
Helicopter simultaneously so loud and not so loud.
I don't.
I'm doing my best here.
Why don't I have my shotgun?
There we go.
Oh gosh, okay.
Ha!
Anyone else?
Trash can attack!
Rapid, please!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Everything's happening, all outwinds.
Oh!
How long does it take, ma'am?
Oh, they're coming for the rooftops.
flashbangs oh did that hurt me oh my gosh where'd you guys
step on me
hey where's it come from
okay was that the last bit oh my god
you better put an end to this just get me to leave her
sheriff you're taking a big chance on a local crazy Lady Al.
I hope you're right about her, or we could kiss this town
goodbye.
I think we're the most right about her.
What other leads are we supposed to go on anyway?
Yay, we did it!
That wasn't so- that was like the easiest ambush that we've
had, I think.
I hope you know how to deal with this wake.
I guess you New Yorkers are used to rough situations like
this.
Kong mutant alligators and Alex Casey shoots the place up
every weekend look I never even carried a gun until a couple
of days ago well my dad used to be a cop there tells some
pretty wild stories stuff like this no no just normal bad
stuff kind of like your books wake I used to tease it looks
like she's flying really low you've read me oh sure we
shouldn't be in the trees I think right a little heavy on
the metaphors maybe nobody's ever said that before the up on
the power plant see the lit building over there and that's
the dam further up the river i can't land here i'll take her
down the road across the river just get me there sheriff
whoa that's a lot of birds
uh-oh bird strike
Bird Strike!
Uh,
they're gonna live, right?
Uh.
I'll
get them.
I'll get them.
Close.
Wait, what happened to all my batteries?
I had like 20!
Did they fall out of my pocket or something?
And my flashlight!
Wait, I have no weapons.
What happened to all my stuff?
Excuse me!
We left them in the chopper.
No, stinking way!
Wow, he picked up everything!
I had to do something about the chain for the door to open.
Ooh, that's kind of spooky the way it's like trying to open
on its own.
It reminds me of when like, uh...
Oh, great.
All this revolver ammo for the revolver that I definitely
have.
Oh.
Yay!
I ever played Undertaker?
pale yellow.
I don't know that game, but I would never say never.
Sorry, guys.
I feel something tickling me this entire time.
I feel like it's like a cat hair.
I had so much stuff.
I was completely loaded up on everything.
And the game took it all from me.
Okay.
Oh.
The darkness wears her face.
Okay.
The darkness controls the daikon.
Wait, what am I?
Am I supposed to shoot this?
No.
Uh...
Is there like a wire cutter around here?
Each level resets your inventory.
I didn't realize that...
But this is...
Not a new chapter.
This is not chapter 6, right?
Like, it's just...
Yeah, it's still chapter 5.
Maybe I do...
Do you think I missed it?
Let's try.
Oh, the wood.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
I have no flares or anything.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah!
I know I saw...
Um...
Shit!
I ran the wrong way.
Oh my gosh, I'm wasting everything.
Ah!
God!
This is terrible.
Why would you...
Oh, the light inside!
You guys are so right.
I didn't even see it.
I'll be honest.
I got so hung up on the fact that I was about to get
ambushed.
Run in and run in and run in and run in and run in.
Oh, God!
Oh, it's...
Oh, please.
Alan, Alan dodge.
Oh, thanks, game.
Really appreciate it.
Alan, bad knees.
Alan, roll.
Alan, Alan do something.
Alan, Alan.
Oh, I got some flares.
Oh, thank goodness.
I realized how truly dependent on everything I am.
Look at this, guys.
We're not in the woods.
We're in...
Industry yard.
Yeah, we love it.
They can't...
The thing is, is, like, they send so many huge guys at me
now.
That it's, like, really difficult to...
to not have more special stuff, you know what I mean?
Yeah, they're sending huge guys!
And here's a new song from a band that...
They always remind me of our local rock legends, the old
gods.
Wait, is this DMCA?
Hugh Morris?
DMCA free song.
Thank you!
Perfect.
Oh, are we gonna have a soundtrack for when we fight the
next guy?
Ow!
Oh,
nice!
Where'd he go?
So there's this guy left, right?
Shit.
I have no more flares.
I'm screwed.
I'm so screwed.
Oh, I have flares, just kidding.
Oh my gosh, there's so many huge guys.
Please!
Ouch!
Oh shit!
Shit!
I'm trying to move.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Holy!
Holy cow!
They're like, uh...
Oh my gosh.
The barrel.
What?
This one right here?
Wow, that one was tough.
Hmm.
It's because I only see them sometimes.
Also, if I'm too close, I'll get hurt too, right?
That's how I feel.
Red with the white... I'm not that stupid, you guys!
I know which ones explode!
I know which ones!
Oh my god!
I know which ones explode!
I've been shooting them before!
What the hell?
You guys think I'm actually stupid, I think.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Like I said, the reason I am hesitant about shooting them is
I'm worried about myself exploding.
But if I am okay, then I guess we'll be okay.
Let's try it.
What if I don't turn on the music?
Screw it.
So if I...
Oh.
If it didn't lock on him, that would be pretty nice too.
Wait.
Oh.
But it's kind of like...
Yeah.
Okay.
It's pretty far.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Shoot!
Okay.
one second
don't be mean you guys don't be mean that's all i want to
say hold on trying to find somebody to time you out because
you're being mean
uh I can't find you, but when I find you again, I'll time
you out because you're being mean.
This is the one of the more annoying fights in the whole
game, so don't worry about it.
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
It's fine.
I'm not annoyed so far.
All right, come here.
Oh, please.
Ah, bam!
Ah, I'm sure he'll get him.
Oh, it's too far.
That sucks.
Oh, whoop!
Okay.
Headshot!
I wish I had my lamp.
Shoot.
Oh, gosh.
I only have one flare left, though.
Oh.
Wait, did I get the other barrel?
Where'd it go?
Oh, God!
Oh,
shoot.
I'm just wasting bullets.
I get so scared about it!
Oh my god, please.
Leave me alone.
I know that I'm shooting them and I'm wasting my ammo,
but...
The guy tried to throw his...
Please!
There's so many guys!
I'm trying to dodge.
I'm trying to dodge to get them more.
I think there's more items on the other side.
But getting through them is crazy.
Like, there's more items over there.
Actually, that just looks like ammo.
It doesn't look like flares.
Yeah, it just looks like ammo.
Dang it.
Oh, this one's hard.
No, the stuff on the shelves is what I'm talking about.
I think it's just ammo, not...
Oh.
Maybe you want a bum rush to the other side.
Let's try that.
Yeah.
I'm not even going to start these.
Where does this guy even come from, for real?
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah, please!
No!
Okay.
Oh, I see, it does hurt me, but...
I guess we kind of got that guy.
Oops.
Oh, geez!
Where did you go from?
Ah!
Please!
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God, oh, my God.
Please shoot that thing.
Shoot that thing.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
This one's so tough.
It's like all big guys too.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, hold on.
The coffee makes me shaky.
I wonder, okay, what if?
Because one thing that it does, is when I try to I like to
aim with it but I guess I don't need to okay what if I go
down here and before he smashes it right before I shoot it
and then he smashes it and then maybe it will explode on him
kid me raged hard at this game
Okay, let's try it.
Alright.
Alright, run, run, run.
Oh, that worked!
Oh my god, I got him!
Oh, yes, I got him!
Yes!
My big brain!
AAAAAAAA!
Where did you come from?
You asshole?
Oh, shoot.
These guys are so fast and scary.
Holy shit.
Ouch.
Shrunk the ammo.
Just pick it up.
Any flares?
Oh, I have one left.
That's right.
Holy shit.
Yes.
Yes, sir.
Oh my god, more!
No, I won't let you charge.
I won't let you charge.
Don't hold me to?
Please let me pick up...
Oh, it's revolver ammo, that's why.
Oh my god, we did...
That was...
That was the stride.
That was the stride, for real.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Well, not really.
I could have exploded more barrels, maybe.
But I did explode.
some and I did get some guys I'm trying to get the I thought
I saw a thermos where are you there you are on the other
side sheesh that one was scary give me to the light please
give me some supplies anything I'll take anything oh check
boy getting that first guy was like it changed the game
honestly it changed the Getting that first guy.
I have one bolt.
You know what?
Time to revolver time, I suppose.
Okay.
I timed it absolutely perfectly.
That first one.
Yeah.
Cross the transformer yard.
What is this?
Metal gear?
Powerplant glowed in the night.
It was close.
But I had to find a way across.
Just swim, Bozo.
Like, what are we talking about?
I had to find a way across.
the water I don't know I think I'm done with Alan wait I
think I'm mad at him I think I'm like shut up Alan yeah all
right who's gonna ambush me nobody please say nobody it's
darkest in the water maybe that is the case huh Maybe.
Oh.
I was expecting like a super, like a, like, you know, like a
big heavy door that's opening.
Oh.
Alan Dodge.
Wait, if I run through...
No.
I don't even think then.
How do I get through?
Alan climb.
Alan climb only once.
It'll get hurt.
Yeah.
I don't want to get zapped.
Obviously.
Alan swim!
I am curious how they are expecting me to get to the other
side.
Oh, there's a bridge over there.
Maybe that.
Oh.
Oh my gosh!
Hi!
Tippy!
Okay.
Oh.
Temporary.
That's fine.
Does it work again?
Oh.
Oh wow!
I can checkpoint anytime I want!
Huh.
I'm looking around.
La la la la!
That did checkpoint me, right?
Yeah, why did Alan write so many ambushes?
Great question.
Okay, there, we got a checkpoint.
Alan Big Brian?
You could call me a writer.
They're
back.
Oh, they're back.
Um, excuse you.
I thought I heard a third guy.
Or saw a third guy, rather.
Kaboom.
Oh, I did- I did.
I 100% did.
I don't care.
They're so big.
They take forever.
They take forever!
especially with this with this um what's the word?
Flashlight I'm gonna wait for it to recharge they're so
tanky
I hear it whispering something's whispering but whatever oh
checkpoint
la la la la la la la la la three flares whoops whoops Can I
go through here?
No.
Alright, who's gonna be over there?
I wonder.
Huh?
Eh?
Well.
I thought I heard...
Yellen.
Oh, thermos!
Thermos, my beloved!
Yeah, I'll come for you!
Come on, Alan.
Just shimmy on through, buddy.
You can do this.
Skinny legend.
It's just teasing you, I know.
Whoa!
Danger zone!
Don't touch anything, okay.
Oh.
Shut the hell up.
This is...
So mean.
Yeah, back up.
Not that way.
I was hoping that would happen.
Stupid.
That was Beast Mode Minto Gaming.
Whoa, I wonder why it's all sealed up.
Why does that look like a trap?
Like, you know, like a...
Oh, look, there's an item in the middle.
Don't you want it?
Page on top of this building?
Oh, I got a checkpoint.
Okay, perfect.
Alan does not know how to jump very well.
Or use his arms.
Oh!
What an interesting setup we have here.
What an interesting setup we got going on.
Oh, she really couldn't have put us, like, further from...
Wait, there was nothing else over there that I needed,
right?
Looks like we dropped down now.
Yeah, because I just see electricity.
Okay, cool.
Um...
Did we miss one?
Oh, no!
I hope not.
The story I had written in the cabin had come true.
Touched by the dark presence, I had written a horror story.
But the end was still missing.
The story was incomplete, and the last unfinished page of
the map manuscripts still sat in the typewriter in the cabin
study.
Oh.
If I could get back there, if I could read the page, then I
could write my own ending to this story and save Alice.
Deus Ex Machina, the whole thing.
It's back towards the entrance of this place.
No kidding, really?
Wait, seriously?
Will the bad...
Will the guys respawn or can we just like run through it
real fast?
I can't believe I missed it.
you saw lying on the ground.
I don't think I saw it.
They shouldn't.
Wait.
Let's, we'll try real quick, because I do obviously want to
collect as many pages as possible.
So back close to where I started.
Wait, oh, yes!
I forgot to turn around!
Oh, okay, okay.
I thought we were having to go, like, you know, actually
back to the beginning.
Oh, good.
Oh, good, good, good.
Making her way through the water pipe alone, Cynthia was
angry at the writer.
Foolish young man, taking unnecessary risks.
And the way he broke the rules, didn't he understand what
was at stake?
Rules?
Since the terrible days in the 70s, she hadn't wavered once.
hard as it had been.
She was tired of protecting the town all these long years
and now only wanted to rest.
It's so funny.
The terrible days in the 70s is such a way to describe that.
That's so funny that it wasn't even this page.
It's this one.
That's funny though.
Well, yeah, what rules?
Fushi gear.
This part was so evil.
thread the needle they're like don't trip what where is OSHA
hello this doesn't seem safe
the terrible days in the 70s can't wait to tell the young
generation I used to watch mint in the 20s the terrible days
in the 20s oh it's like I was surfing checkpoint love to see
it love to see it making sure there's nothing over here okay
I'm gonna try and swim okay actually that was a speedrun
strat so I don't have to walk all the way back okay just
seeing what all I've got Seeing what all I've got.
Okay.
Wait, the bridge doesn't even connect to it either.
How the hell?
How am I supposed to get over there?
Why did they leave me?
Why did Barry, why did they leave me?
Whoa.
Crazy bridge.
It's one of those that like turns.
Oh.
Visual glitch?
Oh my gosh, thermos.
I'm getting a lot of funky glitches today!
Where'd he go?
Alan bugged.
Yeah, I'm getting a lot of funny bugs and glitches today.
Hello.
I'll take that.
Um.
Those guys look like salary men.
They make me laugh.
I'll take that.
Take that and that.
Oh, checkpoint.
Wait, before so.
Before, though.
What's over here?
I got the checkpoint.
Is there anything?
No manuscript?
No ammo?
Just the worst car pile up ever.
The most inconvenient pile up.
in episode one.
Survive jumping into a lake from a cliff.
Alan episode five just dies from falling into the water.
That dude entered like Kramer enters Jerry's apartment.
I also have to wonder why did this happen?
Are we actually murdering people like in the town?
Like is that actually how that works?
Or is it just like a...
Oh my god, I'm probably gonna have to do that.
Survive until...
until the bridge moves kind of situation here huh they're
already dead yesent before I do this though real quick guys
I'm gonna be right back I'm going to the little ghosties
room one second one second one second I will be right back
I'm going fishing wait I'm going fishing I wish wishing I
was fishing okay BRB.
I'm back.
Alrighty, let's fight some zombies.
Let's do this thing.
Use...
Cross the bridge.
So much easier said than done, huh?
What if I just chill in here for now?
What if I chill in here and wait for it to...
finish?
Did you catch any fish?
Actually, I left the idle fishing game go...
Wait, what's happening?
Hello?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
We're good?
Was that supposed to happen?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh my god, we made it.
Wait, but...
More birds!
Oh shoot!
I just have to stay on this side.
And we'll reach it.
More birds.
Okay.
I don't know if there was anything else on there, but I
don't really care.
Night Springs!
Are we men dreaming of being butterflies or butterflies that
dream of being men?
Who's dreaming of being a butterfly?
Wait, what?
And yet, some of us can find concrete proof of the nature of
our existence.
The whole building is shaking while the bridge is like...
Wait, is it not gonna stop?
Am I supposed to be the one to stop it?
Just does that.
It's in the basement.
Oh, Martha.
Whoa.
I
can't look straight at it.
Yes, I'm sorry about that.
What the heck?
How did you get here?
Well, I'm trying to work.
Did you put this thing here?
In a way, to be more precise, I put everything here but
that.
Really?
But what is it?
Oh, I guess the temptation is to call it a hole.
Yeah, it's a hole.
It's really an absence of a profound lack of reality.
So it's like a black hole?
In Martha's basement?
Who voiced these slaves?
two old ladies and put something really weird in the
basement it was a great start but i'm completely blocked now
i can't imagine what i was up to what what well surely it's
just an ordinary basement is it he wrote them why did you
call your friend here then well i i don't know oh well can
you just ignore it no no i couldn't do that it would
probably turn into a plot hole a plot whole enterprise oh my
god the building is shaking again
i can't hear over the noise of the you should just go back
upstairs for a cup of coffee while i try to figure out what
i'm up to well if you think that's best maybe i should just
stop here or is that too moronic he's stuck in the plot hole
is that too moronic Beat.
You can tell.
It's a fine line between the stupid and the sublime.
Night Springs.
Woo!
Nice.
All right.
Are they still after me or...
Can't tell.
Checkpoint, please.
Oh.
Oh!
Coast Guard.
Oh, nice.
You're almost at the power plant.
Keep going.
I'll give you support.
Holy cow, they're gonna give me support.
Wait, this is awesome.
Wait, is there anything over here?
One second.
So meta, I know, right?
One second, one second.
There's so many cars here.
Like, why are there actually so...
I guess all these people that were leaving work from the
power plant, I have to imagine.
Pequod!
Whoa, you're fast.
Support, support, support.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh!
Wait, you're in the light!
Excuse me!
Oh my gosh.
Are we moving again?
Come on.
Wait, where are we going?
Which way is this?
Hello?
Is it?
Okay.
I'll just keep going then.
Oh, okay.
Why?
Why are you going so fast?
Oh my gosh.
My dodge skills are unmatched.
Whoa!
Jeez!
Oh my god!
Sorry.
The bug, the bug, the bug, the bug.
Oh shit, oh shit!
They all three came at me at once!
The bug, the bug?
Okay.
Oh my gosh, it takes me out every time.
I think I need to, like, use this bad boy.
Oh my god.
Oh, they're so strong.
They're so stinking strong.
um okay hold on let's uh i'm i'm preparing myself real quick
i got clogged hard it's so funny that they can go into this
light right why is that allowed
flashbang that's right that's right
oh my gosh come
on you
I'm not wasting my shotgun ammo on you.
Okay.
Helly light hits different, I guess.
Yeah, what the heck is this?
Hold on, I'm letting my...
I just have the flare gun ready.
The flashbang really did help, though.
Alright.
I find...
Okay, let's go.
This helicopter support sucks.
What is this?
What kind of support?
Get inside!
Okay!
Where's inside?
Hold on.
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
That was so close.
Oops, birds, yeah.
Wait, what's over here?
Secret?
The support lasted two seconds.
Oh, nice.
Take everything.
Yes, very good.
Awesome.
Yeah, the music stopped.
Is that just a flare on the ground?
Wait, no checkpoint?
Oh, so I mean.
Okay, I'm like...
right outside the I'm right outside can we where's the where
is the entrance please why is there no easy entrance what is
this spooky scary oh that's a leaf
ah i was on some guy safe haven on
the power plant sign i'd seen a version painted all over the
area signifying hidden caches of supplies nice yeah yeah
safe haven safe haven Alan run Alan find trust no one in the
dark she says we know we know we know what oh it's electric
this guy getting electrified if you don't see the bolt of
lightning it just looks very confusing It looks very
confusing what it's like implying.
You know?
Do you have any flares?
Safe haven, she says.
Generator hall.
I'm just exploring.
Let's go in.
Excuse me.
Miss Weaver, Cynthia.
I'm a friend.
I'm a friend!
You knew Zane, Thomas Zane.
You're the lady of the light in the song.
You can help me.
about time young man i've been waiting a very long time for
you nice oh my gosh i hope her power doesn't fail because of
me you know like i kind of tend to bring terribleness
wherever i go you know like i kind of bring misfortune to
everybody who uh excuse me what do you say you need to drive
the darkness back The well-lit room is at the dam.
I built the room to keep it safe.
Will it help me find Alice?
Will it get me back to the cabin?
Fine, let's go.
I can get my friends to come back with the helicopter.
Oh, we won't go outside.
Never at night.
That's rule number one.
Yeah.
You've been breaking the rules, young man, and where has
that gotten us?
Hmm?
No, I have a secret route, a lit route.
Oh.
at the transformer yard it's the rain all the reserve power
without it the pipe will go dark the power to the yard must
be cut let me guess you want me to do it young man you're
the one who likes to break the rules i can't be outside in
the dark she's like petting her lamp which is outside
seriously i like this darkness waits in my dreams i miss you
tom batteries.
Oh, never mind.
You got lucky.
Cut the power to the transformer yard.
I'm taking her thermos even.
I have been preparing for these times, the dark tides.
You have found my caches.
Yeah, I've been taking everything.
See the signs.
Very few people can.
Yes, please.
Take what you need.
Oh, see, I'm not stealing.
This is all for you, for the likes of us.
We do Tom's work, don't we?
Hurry!
The switch is on the wall facing the shore.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, that's my old flashlight.
Oh, my goodness.
Why is it so bright?
Oh, it's batteries.
I don't need anymore.
I think those are batteries, too, yeah.
So I gotta go cut the power to...
I cannot take you to the well-lit room if the lights and the
pipe go out.
You must go outside to use the emergency switch.
Okay, okay!
One second, you said take all I need.
I am!
That's what I'm doing right now, lady.
Oh, man.
I do have four of these bad boys.
No, it's not dark.
Light.
Alright, so it's where?
Where is this?
The transform?
Okay.
Is that- Oh, it's here.
Thanks, I guess.
What does this do?
If only this were it, right?
If only if it were so easy.
Can't go in there.
All right.
Very cool.
Cut the...
Back up, buddy!
Back up!
You both of you!
Oh, shoot.
That didn't get you at all.
Oh!
Oh, I forgot that I was holding this way.
Oops.
Well, that worked.
The other guy was on me anyway.
I just wasted so many things.
Oh, okay.
Where the hell did you come from?
Overkill.
The druid sent me to cut the power to the transformer yard.
I was willing to do grunt work for her to get her to help
me.
Yeah, exactly.
I hoped Weaver was dependable.
I'd stumbled into this crazy world a little over a week ago.
She had been living this insanity for decades.
Darkness waits.
Why did you write that there?
The game gives you tons of resources.
It does until it doesn't.
But yeah, you're right.
It does.
For the most part.
Never go.
Rule one.
Never go out.
Someone's going to bust out of there.
When we're like coming back, someone's definitely...
Oh.
No, wait.
This is her place.
Never mind.
We might be okay.
You're so cute in your black outfit.
Thank you.
I feel like it fits the tone of the game, right?
Why is that thing shaking?
Is he cold?
If you're cold, he's cold.
I'm working on a coding assignment for my college class and
just realized the project file is called lights off.
No!
He's shivering.
Oh.
We're moving.
Slightly.
What's happening?
Oh.
Interesting.
Okay, anyway, sorry.
I'm so easily...
that would cut the power that went all the way over there
now i had to find a way to reach it okay alan think
floodgate controls all right interesting okay what we got
going on over here oh my gosh alan puzzle time let's go
let's go figure out the gates yeah yeah yeah what's that
kill switch rule three always remember the lantern what's
rule number two
did it.
I think.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh no!
Never mind.
I didn't realize this one was blocked.
Okay, wait.
So I think we have to get this unblocked first.
Okay, just kidding.
Alright.
Here I was thinking I had the biggest brain in the whole
universe.
What's this one do?
And what's this one do?
So if I press this one, is it go back to the first thing?
It's been a beautiful 21 months in the meantime.
Thank you.
Alan Kick.
rule number two keep the lights on oh Alan punch
so now we have to get all three of them nice try I really
thought that was the solution
you thought again I really did floodgate controls to be by
authorized personnel only.
Oh, man.
Okay, wait.
Maybe it's number two.
Oh, yeah.
Actually, that works.
You know what?
Actually, I was making it more difficult.
Oh, wait.
No, it doesn't.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, hold on.
If I do this, does it do all three?
Ah, ah, ah.
Oh,
yeah, I know, I know.
Oh, more shotgun ammo, actually.
Nice shot, thank you.
All right, wait, can I...
Is this...
Okay, no, I have to run how I did before.
Oh my gosh, this is going to be stressful.
That's what I'm thinking.
Oh!
Oh, but now this is open.
No, it is not.
The transporter yard would dark and dead.
Weaver's water pipe passage should now be good to go.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, technically you did, Alan.
So true.
Oh my gosh, please run.
Please run.
Checkpoint.
Go, go, go.
Wait, I'm going to get my flare out instead.
Yeah, so I can just run with it.
Oh!
Why can't I go through the door?
That's why.
Why is this not open?
Open the door?
Open your...
Oh god!
We're running?
Wait, what was that?
Oh, it was the...
Oh my gosh.
I did it!
This way, young man.
Follow me.
Come, come.
The pipe's empty now.
We're ready to go.
Okay, cool.
I was a little stressful, lady.
This way, we need to go.
Okay.
I knew them both, Tom, and...
Barbara, I had such a crush on him.
Such a beautiful man.
I was jealous.
There was a part of me that was maybe a little glad when she
had the accident.
And then Tom started riding and woke the darkness up.
He tried to bring it back, but you can't do that.
There are no free rides like that.
What is...
What is she just...
In that case, young man, perhaps you're a smarter man than
Tom was.
The witch looked like her.
Barbara was sweet.
He didn't understand until it was too late.
He tried to undo it, wrote himself, everything he'd ever
written out of the world.
Like all of this unprompted.
For real.
He was so famous.
And afterward, no one knew.
No.
Oh.
He left only one thing behind in my game in case it happened
again.
Insurance.
He trusted me.
Or perhaps mused me a little.
Oh.
Tom knew how I felt.
Knew I wouldn't refuse him.
I built the well-lit room and put it there.
I curse you, Tom Zade.
We are characters trapped in a story you have written.
And none of us will survive to see the end.
But if the darkness isn't stopped, she'll twist the story to
her own dark ends.
How do you know all this?
Tom, that's the way he wrote it.
Oh.
He still talks to me.
In television, beyond.
In the television?
We have both been touched by the darkness, young man.
He saved us both by the light, but the darkness stays here.
You need help with that?
This pipe will take us directly to the well-lit room.
Okay, I need to call my friends.
Tell them where we're going.
Little, little, little.
Hello?
Ow!
Barry, oh my gosh.
That's Alan Wake using AI.
okay i'll tell sarah it's sarah now whoa
what just happened
we gotta go see if they're okay they're probably dead you
must reach the well-lit room this is no time to be a selfish
idiot that's my best friend wait we're leaving oh my
freaking god no oh my god they're right there i'll be a fool
i'll use the pipe i'll meet you at the dam if you make it
wait why can't i use the pipe after i check on my friends
at least i didn't have to worry about her she knew how to
stay safe i can get back in there oh my god
no uh no i can't get back in there dummy when she went she
down that's it that's all you got The well-lit room.
I was calling it the well-lit room.
It's so funny.
I don't know why.
It's just like...
Oh my god.
It's one thing after another.
Why did you write it like this, Alan?
Why did you write it like this?
I'll never forgive you.
Oh, we still have two more missing pages, right?
Yeah.
Sarah was almost starting to relax.
Maybe they could turn this into a win yet.
Suddenly, there was a piercing sound like a table saw going
wild as a hundred birds made out of shadows swarmed into the
rotor.
The chopper bucked wildly and the board lit up, telling her
what she already knew.
They were going down.
Barry Wheeler screamed next to her.
You know, at any point, they could have locked or sorry,
they could have landed the helicopter and joined us in the
pipe.
At any point, they could have landed the helicopter.
And joined us walking to the room.
Why?
Why did they not do that?
I'm going to become the Joker.
I'm just...
Oh,
I just...
Yeah.
Take him out.
Yeah!
Oh shit!
I
didn't have enough battery.
Wait, I saw something.
Yeah!
She's jonkling out.
I am!
Oh my gosh!
They're just so stupid!
Oh, this is a checkpoint I just realized.
Nice.
He's the logger.
The log.
Are they coming after me?
Oh yes.
Oh, there was a log here we could have gone down.
That's fine.
Nice.
Oh, there's a log here we got across.
Oh,
that was close.
I didn't even see them.
I was trying to aim for other guys.
Just reached the crash site!
Barry!
Sheriff Baker!
Sarah!
They already left?
Or they fell.
No, they're alive.
I believe.
The crash site looked bad, but as far as I could tell, the
wreck was empty.
Yeah?
Yeah, that's true.
Pick up Flare.
Oh.
yeah thanks oh another flare oh my gosh I'm like a kid in
candy any more flares the well lit oh it's such a good thing
that we're headed to the well lit it's the same road right
any other flares
very very very
Keep hitting them!
Oh,
shoot.
Yeah, baby.
That's the strong stuff.
Keep hitting them.
You know when to make an entrance wake.
We were ready to make like Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid.
I have a different ending in mind.
Ha ha ha ha.
I'm fine.
Thanks for asking.
are back!
I hear whispers.
Are you guys flashing?
Oh, yes, yes.
Wait.
Oh, here.
Up here, up here.
Okay, okay.
Keep hitting him.
This is kind of far.
Hello?
Oh, okay, we got it.
Yahoo!
Okay.
Oh, thank you, Sheriff.
And friends.
Is this, this is not where we're supposed to go, right?
Or maybe it is.
A different way, technically, I suppose.
We gotta get to the top of the dam.
Oh yeah, we could have, okay, okay.
Nice.
Page!
Where?
There's a page somewhere?
I don't see.
Pizza dinner!
I want some pizza!
Well, I don't see a page.
They're usually very...
Very bright.
Oh, my flare gun is equipped.
Thank you.
I want pizza.
Sounds good.
when you spend most of your night running uphill while a
crazy bunch of demon hicks try to take your head off with an
axe you know your helicopter crash landed in night springs
so true he's already said this before I'm never gonna get
used to this he's already said this before I'm never I
should have kept that gym membership are you know what
you'll save your your breath that's the elevator we need to
take okay you'll save your breath if you stop talking so
much Barry it's real you can't believe I saw something oh oh
crap there's more than one of them uh nothing moves like
that it's impossible are is are we really questioning stuff
I'm working on it.
He's too fast.
I can't get a shot.
I'm working on it.
Where'd he go?
No, there!
Ow, they're all over the place.
Just keep walking.
How many of them are there?
Where'd that one go?
There's like two, right?
Oh shoot.
Okay, I got one.
All me, all me.
How the hell did that freak go?
Wait, this is bad.
This is really bad.
All me, all me?
Nice.
Keep winning them.
Just got a promotion!
Celebrated by buying a ticket to Ochi Uplink.
I wonder who is going to be there.
Congratulations!
Oh my gosh.
Hey, how?
I got a bad feeling.
Let's keep our eyes open.
This is a bad idea.
I know we're going to regret this.
Thermus.
Wait, call the elevator.
I'm keeping watch.
I think I hear something moving around.
Stop saying that.
You're freaking me out.
Yeah, it will be an Oshi Outlink with a dancer too!
Hope to see you guys there.
Oh, we have full everything.
Calling the elevator and now we wait for it to come down
very, very slowly.
And we will be ambushed in the meantime.
Heads up!
Here they come!
Right on cue!
Oh no!
Why is everything in slow motion?
Barry, don't get too close, buddy.
Let me handle this.
I swear this is the slowest elevator, I guess.
Le epic.
Oh, I just saw them literally spawn in the place.
Barry is recognizing video game logic.
Yeah, buddy.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, why did I click the wrong button instead of running?
Oh, my gosh.
I am.
It's extra safety, I guess.
I clicked the other one instead of run.
We're almost there.
There's an entrance into the dam at the top.
What's the plan, Wake?
crazy but she's got something Zane left behind something to
fix yeah she's also like a fangirl could you be a little
more vague Thomas Zane seriously might as well be Paul
Bunyan or Bigfoot yeah well he was real he was real to me
I'm surprised the elevator actually worked oh my gosh let's
be careful okay I'm surprised it actually didn't break on us
or something I hate this
Okay, wake.
There's a button over there that opens the door.
There is.
Oh, this one?
Wait, hold on.
Oh, well-lit room?
Oh my gosh, it's the well-lit room!
Wait, what's...
I'm looking for any manuscripts, but I don't see any pages.
Do they need Alan alive?
Great question.
Oh, I have to hold it?
I think something's broken.
Hold the button down so we can get in.
Oh, so you guys can get in.
Okay.
Sure.
What's going on?
We can get to the dam through here.
What's happening out there?
You guys go ahead and find Weaver.
She should be in the dam now.
I'll have to make it alone through the top.
Okay, good luck.
Don't get yourself killed.
Now, please be careful.
I'll take good care of Barry Wade.
You just look after yourself.
I'm not even amused right now.
Oh!
You gotta be kidding me.
That, no.
You did this.
Oh my gosh.
There goes my last flare, too.
I don't want to accidentally use that.
It's because I'm holding.
Holding down, I often accidentally hit RB because I'm
holding down LT to focus and so I don't think to like dodge
or like, you know, because I'm my index finger.
Whatever, it's fine.
Oh, there's a page.
It is what it is.
Small fingers.
Yeah, I think I actually mixed, actually, actually missed
one.
That's so upsetting.
Thomas Zane knew he had to remove all that had made this
horror possible including himself that was the only way to
banish the dark presence he had unleashed and now looked at
him through the eyes of his dead love dead love despite his
best efforts his dead love someday return so even as he
wrote himself and his work out of existence he added a
loophole as insurance an exception to the rule anything of
his stored in a shoebox would remain interested hot dog hot
dog just finished work Don't know if this has been brought
up yet, but how many times did you get pinged about the
Koharu Nendo news?
Only a couple times, but it showed up naturally in my
Twitter page, like in my Twitter for you, so.
Drew, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
My dead love.
Oh, this game pisses me off.
Am I supposed to?
Oh, this way.
My bad.
See, it's so bright here, right?
Like, I'm like, there's no way anything could be around, but
that's not the case, apparently.
Reach the top of the dam.
So much easier said than...
So much easier said than done.
Oh, gosh.
Turn around!
Oh!
They're from all over!
Yeah!
That's right.
The well-lit...
Wait, the one that was at the bottom wasn't the well-it
room?
God damn it.
Oh, I should reload my gun.
There we go.
Oh, flare?
Ah!
I was ridiculously outnumbered.
The searchlight could even the odds.
Oh.
You're right.
Uh, use?
Patrol.
Oh, boost.
I hope nobody's coming up from behind me.
That'd be pretty bad if anybody came up from behind me.
Just saying.
Oh my god, there's so many guys.
Wait, what the heck is this?
Oh god!
Like I said!
Stop throwing things at me.
Turrets, actually.
Defeat the taker.
No, okay.
You will go no further.
Oh, the trees!
Oh shoot, wait, that's actually kind of bad.
Wait.
Ooh.
Escape the dark presence!
Oh, okay.
Running, running, running, running.
Is it this guy?
Could really use a well-lit room right now.
Oh.
I think I went the wrong way.
This way.
Oh!
Woo!
Reach the top of the dam, they said.
It will be easier after you get to the top, they said.
Here's a well-lit room, they said!
Oh my goodness.
Thermus, they said!
Holy cow!
Oh shoot.
Oops.
Sorry.
Sorry, I didn't realize that it was...
Where am I?
Oh, up here.
Alan leap!
That's what he... Alan do!
Alan escape.
Ah, yep!
Oh shoot!
Oh my god, that was close.
Well lit, Rube!
Oh shoot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
It's the well-lit room!
Baby?
Woo!
Poorly lit damn.
Golly!
I'm glad I was wrong.
But it was a foolish chance to take.
Ah, whatever.
Don't worry about the noise.
We're safe here.
Don't say that.
room for many many years now there is no shadow in the
well-lit room the hour is fail-safe and all the bulbs are
numbered and changed regularly based on their make and model
oh my god it's the well-lit room yeah nothing can go wrong
in the well-lit room I guess we're gonna make our game plan
in here and then there's an old army base at raincoat point
north of here it was active during the second world war they
operated here back then they must have built this yes they
did it's my place now i stole it it's my precious
what if it stops being well lit never it couldn't it
couldn't whoa then i won't need to worry about the room
anymore because six and 33 and 118 need changing soon and i
don't want to climb up the ladder to change them because
it's very late I'm tired.
And if you take it, I won't have to do that anymore.
That's so well it.
The page was autobiographical.
A memory from my childhood.
But I didn't write this.
It was a page written by Thomas Zane.
Thomas Zane?
None of them were supposed to exist anymore.
Alan, seven years old, would fight sleep to the bitter end.
When he did sleep, he soon woke up, screaming that
nightmares fresh in his mind.
Light bulbs.
One evening, his mother said...
never been to the lighting section of a home depot she
called it the clicker and clicking the switch would turn on
a magical light that would drive the beast away yes yes to
imbue the talisman with all possible power she added that it
had been given to her by Alan's father Alan never knew him
and anything of his took on mythical proportions in his mind
wait so I can click the button am I gonna become all
powerful slept like a baby now almost 30 years later Alan
thought of this as he stood on the rim of Holdren Lake, the
clicker in his hand.
He took a deep breath and jumped.
My mind swirled.
I'd given the clicker to Alice, yet it was here.
Zane had written it into existence in a story I had written.
I can get to her now.
I can finish this.
Yeah!
Shut the door.
Oh, watch your foot.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
End of episode 5.
We got the clicker, baby.
I am going to run real quick and grab...
I have some food that I was like...
I just know how to grab it so I can eat it and have a little
snack before episode 6.
One second, I'll be right back.
No DMs here.
Yeah, I'll just leave it running.
So you can leave, listen.
Ah, yeah.
Look at that.
Thank you.
I'm just going to eat some of this real quick and then...
One thing that's good about coffee is it keeps me focused.
Well, not focused.
It keeps me...
But then it also makes me so hungry.
Outside of Alan Wake, they make good music.
What's the band called again?
Poets of the Fall.
Caffeine is supposed to be an appetite suppressor?
Not for me.
It makes my metabolism go I'm a hungry ghost.
They did music for Max Payne too.
That's so awesome.
Studio just really likes them.
Same, I drink coffee and I get ravenous.
Yeah!
Koi!
Happy birthday!
I've been playing MGSV with the subsistence mod and so Minto
mods, Minto mods!
So much fun!
Happy birthday!
What am I?
Happy birthday Koi!
I'm glad you're having fun with it.
Is the last chapter super duper long or is it about the
same?
This chapter wasn't so bad.
slightly shorter a few hours still okay all good i was like
i if i if we were going 10 hours today i was ready for it so
i was that's why i was like we'll start early we'll go we'll
go we'll go to the end
but doesn't seem like we'll need to do that
probably a lot of fights i bet Probably.
It's selfish, but I hope it takes longer.
Oh, do you want to hang out with me?
Little needy eyeball.
DLC will continue.
The story will be another stream.
Oh, yes, the DLC will be another stream.
Yeah, yeah.
Most likely.
How do I think about it?
Probably.
Previously on Alan Wake, a horror story that has come true.
Thomas Zane did the same in the 70s.
That's a crazy interpose of the fall when he's giving up.
If I continue like the dark presence wants me to, the story
I'm writing won't save Alice.
It's a horror story.
Power balance while Mid beats his peak.
You're the lady of the light.
You must have been behind to help me.
The clicker.
Alan thought of this as he stood on the rim of Cauldron
Lake.
The clicker in his hand.
He took a deep breath and jumped.
I can get to her now.
I can finish this.
Is there a romance happening between Barry and the sheriff?
Because it...
Hudson River.
New York.
Two years ago.
No.
Barif?
They have a ship name?
What's he doing with his arm like that?
My head was about to explode and the light hurt my eyes.
I needed my sunglasses and painkillers to dull the pain.
He was like pretending to hold a gun.
In one of my finer moments of self-deception, I swore to
quit drinking.
Alan.
Alan?
Alan, no self-control.
Oh.
Where is my sunglasses?
I wasn't sure if I could face the world without my
sunglasses.
And something for my headache.
Oh my god, it's so bright.
Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
The pills worked fast.
started to seem bearable again this tiny tiny little washing
machine I'll never forget no water I can't I don't know how
people can do that oh there's my sunglasses oh Alan cool the
sunglasses made the world look bearable now I could keep my
eyes open without feeling like a vampire in the Sun did it
actually or did they just turn down the brightness because
it almost feels like they was a message waiting for me on
the machine.
It almost feels like they actually darkened it a little bit.
Yeah.
Our glasses.
I'm just looking around a little bit.
Looking for a thermos.
Sorry.
I have an obsession.
I have a problem and I recognize it.
Okay.
Um...
You have one new message.
Ow!
Are you still asleep?
Very.
Wakey, wakey!
You should have your show on your TiVo.
If Alice wasn't too mad to record it, as she called me
earlier and really chewed me out.
Yeah, yeah, we went a little overboard last night.
But parties are a part of this business.
TiVo.
I'm saying this is your friend.
She's not doing your career any favors by trying to run your
life like that, okay?
Talk to you later, Al.
Watch the show.
What?
Barry's like, divorce, babe.
Divorce.
Where's the TV?
Oh, here.
The Harry Barrett Show.
Garrett Show.
Bam.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
We have a great show tonight.
I've been talking with...
This is our show.
Wait, is that?
Oh!
The sudden stop.
Oh my gosh, it's Alan Wake in front of the green screen.
Look, I'm going to be honest here.
Is that wise?
No, but I'm going to do it.
I think I would have punched this guy.
But this one, I actually read from cover to cover.
I mean, I'm a big fan.
Wow, thanks.
Now, this might be a spoiler for those who haven't read the
book yet.
Based on the sales figures, the two people out there who
haven't read the book yet.
this last book is all about the death of the main character
the hard-boiled New York oh no he kills off Alex Casey now
there's been a lot of outrage about this why the hell did
you kill Casey spoilers wait a second maybe not everybody
read the book no seriously though seven years and six books
is a long time he was a gloomy guy to spend all your working
hours with and it was a good run but it's time to explore
new things my next book will be a departure from the old for
me you selfish bastard always thinking of yourself now
you've certainly given us a lot of entertainment over the
years okay now that you mentioned it oh it's like the
fastest supplies ever with his love life with the ladies was
that autobiographical in anyway yeah no kidding casey's lady
friends tended to die on him with casey it was all about his
pain no nothing autobiographical about that i'm a happily
married man my wife is my muse My life is my muse.
That's great to hear.
So, how's the publicity tour been treating you?
Good?
Great.
But I gotta say, I'm glad to be back home in New York.
With the glasses on, he kinda looks like the guy who made
the room.
Ooh.
Well, that guy was really in my face.
Tommy, why so?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know that wasn't cool.
Well, you are famous for that temper.
I'm trying to show you the first, but my head is annoyed.
See you.
Well, your latest novel is called The Sudden Stop, and it's
in bookstores now.
Go get it.
That means the two of you out there who haven't bought it
yet.
Ladies and gentlemen, that's all we have for you tonight.
I did now.
I want to thank all our guests for the evening, Alan Wake,
Sam Lake.
What's more, do the face work, Sam?
And our musical guests, Sam Lake?
Thank you.
At least I've been funny.
Oh my gosh, it's Bo, it's on the phone!
Oh my gosh, I didn't say anything stupid if that's what you
want to know.
Okay, grumpy.
You want an aspirin or something?
Are you going to start with me about drinking now?
You know what?
Go back to sleep, Alan.
Why are you being such a do-do head?
Oh my gosh.
I did not hear her.
I did not.
Now you can't even talk to me?
Well, this morning I was angry because you said you'd be
home at midnight and you showed up at 7 a.m.
and passed out in mid-sentence.
Now I'm over it.
Are you angry?
This goddamn tour.
It's gotten out of hand.
Oh, honey.
It's almost over, right?
We can get back to normal.
And you can start writing again.
Do the face again.
I'm sorry, honey.
Alan, you're not thinking straight.
Just take a shower and go back to bed, huh?
How old?
Yeah, you're right, honey.
How old is Alan?
Once this is over, let's go away together.
I'll vacation.
Just you and me.
Some peace and quiet.
The lady kept calling him young man.
His 30s.
Rough.
Present day.
The clicker was the key to the cabin.
I had to return to Carbon Lake to save Alice.
Yeah, plans to stream Alan Wake 2?
Yeah, that's why I started Alan Wake 1.
I'm going back to the lake to finish this.
I'm going to write an ending to the story in the manuscript
on my own terms to make it all right Why can't you just
write it here?
The last page is still in the typewriter.
I need to read it first.
Everything needs to be just right.
Zane tried to cut some corners And it didn't end well.
Okay, ready when you are.
Yeah, we're the team I'm sorry, Sarah, but I need to do this
alone.
No, Barry take her gun.
Oh my god.
Why?
Miss Weaver closed the door when I leave.
What?
what what what good luck Alan why Alan why why see you later
what I'm about to I can't deal I can't take this man anymore
when I got out it was wool and sunny I'd flick the switch of
the clicker had it done this I didn't stop to question it I
had to take advantage of the sunlight to get to the lake on
zane's page i'd stood on the rim of cauldron lake about to
use the clicker that's where i was headed imagine the game
is like okay now backtrack from the beginning
i'm so angry right now we had the dream team the three of us
the pacific northwest landscape it was hard not to let doubt
creep in one last time i could still chalk everything up to
a dream a delusion i had enough imagination to make up
something like this what having been in the cabin all this
time trapped in a story inside my head gone mad from grief
over alice's death like hartman had claimed there would be
no way of knowing i told myself it didn't really matter my
course was set no i was just kidding when i said we We have
to...
I was just kidding you.
I said we have to go all the way back to...
I was just kidding about that.
Visit the haunted witches ladle.
What?
I want to go there.
Someone that just turned 34 that cut deep, Minto.
Sorry.
No, I don't mean it.
You have to forgive me.
I mean, to be fair, I'm still 19.
Everybody's old to me.
How long have we been 19?
A while.
Wow, look at that view.
Wow, wow!
That's the PNW.
Scenic area!
Also, aka a place to buy a new car.
I mean, not buy.
Fine.
Oh, why would you leave your car here at the scenic area,
you dummy dumb?
I can't believe we actually are having to...
Oh my god.
But it's daytime, so I will stop and I will grab things.
Did I just knock that over?
Alan Vandalize!
The Majestic Motel.
Just down the road, come on in!
Kitchenette in every room!
Nice.
Oh, oh, okay, nope, it's still daylight.
Don't let the game fool you.
They were like...
They were like, oh, it's daylight, you said?
Nah, we're just kidding, it is.
Nah, we're just kidding.
We're just joshing.
Logging.
Oh, what if you want another car?
I cannot believe.
Do I have a map?
No.
I just have the little yellow dot to guide me.
Oh, we couldn't go this way anyway.
Why was that?
This thing is so rusty except that one white part at the
top.
Wow.
Alan Explorer!
Easter eggs.
Can you take the loader?
Which was that?
Is that this?
Oh wait.
There's a little shack over here.
there?
Hold on.
Sorry, I am trying to search for supplies and stuff.
And manuscript pages.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, uh-huh.
Search and you shall be rewarded.
See?
Okay.
I was right here.
I completely blind.
The VTuber is blind.
I don't know why the game is kind of glitching out on me.
Let's switch cars.
I love Alan Wake GTA mod.
So great.
I mean, there's nobody on these streets anyway.
Why do I have to worry about it?
Oh.
Oh, what's here?
Alan Theft.
Yeah, Alan Theft Auto.
Grand Theft Allen.
GTI!
Is there
anything even in here?
Oh!
Shut up, a thermos.
But I meant inside the house.
How do you get inside?
Ah, fascinating.
I guess it's the boarded up room or door, I mean.
Bright Falls, Deer Festival, cuisine, trophies, hunting,
family fun.
That looks like one of those billboards that they just leave
up all year.
You think I can push through here?
That was extremely...
The darkness had touched me.
There was a link between us.
Always would be.
I could feel its presence again getting closer.
I have no car anymore!
Can I drive this one?
Damn.
Dang it.
What's that in the middle of the road?
Oh.
I will kill your wife.
Oh, come on.
Oh!
What just happened?
Did my finger slip and I didn't realize?
I didn't press it, though.
Funky.
I will kill your wife.
Magic?
Probably me messing up.
My bad.
The Dark Presence wants to stop Wake.
The Dark Presence was no longer trying to capture the writer
so he could create the ending it wanted.
The writer knew too much.
The Clicker.
And he carried a weapon left behind by Thomas Zane.
Something that could hurt it.
was doing everything in its power to simply stop the rider
from ever reaching Calderon Lake and the dark place it came
from.
Whoa, look how many pages there are that I can't get.
Oh, there's only, there's so few actually.
No, my light!
Wait, I don't have a clicker.
I could drive this though, right?
Oh yeah!
I wanted it to be daytime when we went back to the lake.
Another abandoned car, another abandoned car.
That one doesn't look like it's such a good condition.
Can I go this way?
Uh.
Getting Grand Theft Allen before GTA 6 is crazy.
Can I go in?
Oh, nice.
Checkpoint.
Exam.
Based on the signature in the motel register, Agent
Nightingale had stayed here in room number two.
Oh.
Do we want the shotgun or the hunting rifle?
Wait.
I think the hunting rifle is good.
The Majestic Motel.
General Info.
Refundable $100.
security depositors required on all reservations no personal
checks accepted we take all major credit cards and bank
cards checkout is 10 a.m no loud music no pets oh one
vehicle per unit okay
why is this town so empty oh thermos ew nasty in the
bathroom even hundred dollars for a motel no i think it's a
hundred dollar deposit but you get it back I'm kind of
confused actually wait are we going to room 2 oh excuse me
Mr. No oh
he slept with photos of of Barry
uh okay this guy is God right he's dead dead or It had
obviously been the room where Agent Nightingale had stayed
when he hadn't been busy harassing me.
He kept the sheet so perfect.
But he slept with no pillow.
This guy is a freak.
How would he feel right now knowing that I'm in his bed?
One little monkey jumping on the bed.
Hey!
Oh my god!
Where'd he go?
Oh, I killed him.
I'm in the light.
La la la la la la.
Okay.
Can I go into any other rooms?
Dang.
People actually lock their doors.
Insane information.
Can I...
Oh.
Oh, you are still here.
And you too.
Oh my god!
I did it again!
What's wrong with me?
So my gosh.
I need to unequip.
Why do I...
Why have I suddenly started, like, pressing this instead of
dodging?
I'm so stupid I've like trained myself in the worst way Ah
Beep Beep
At least it works I know but the flashbangs are so pricey
Let's see if there's anything over there Okay let's just go
Oh I
think I'm safe right here Oh
Hello?
Okay.
Checkpoint reached!
I'm like getting my, what's it called?
It's all mixed up.
I'm pressing like all the wrong buttons.
What the heck is wrong with me?
As long as they give me more.
Eventually.
Where'd he go?
There we go.
You would think whatever is flashing in my face would be
enough light to take care of the...
Ah!
Bully!
Yeah!
Sure.
What?
Are you okay?
Are you evil?
Oh, everything's evil.
Of course you are.
Oh my god!
Fight past the poltergeists.
It's kind of fun.
What is this?
Is that a light?
Is that a manuscript?
What is this?
I'm gonna die.
From these freaking things.
Is it a page?
I can't tell.
Yeah, it looks like one, right?
Ugh.
What?
What is?
Is it a light?
I think it's a light.
Oh, it's a light.
That's so funny.
That's so silly.
Now in jump.
Oh, dodge!
Okay.
I think there was something behind me.
Dodge, dodge, dodge!
Ah, geez.
Where's the other one?
Right here.
Yeah!
I think there was something behind me, but,
uh...
Woo!
You.
Oh.
Oh, dang it!
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
Hold on, I'm letting my health regen a little bit on my
battery.
Okay, we're good.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Please, let me move.
I'm trying.
Is it...
Which part is it?
Woo!
George!
Road, road, road!
Is that just a...
a square of...
of light?
Oh my god, they gave us a new car.
Awesome.
This is ridiculous.
All during Deer Festival.
They couldn't have picked the worst time, right?
Oh my god!
But I'm stuck on the road.
Oh,
uh...
Evil car!
Wait, it's a monster car!
Wait!
Evil monster car!
Can
I get it still?
I'm going into the well-lit room.
Why is there a boat?
Oh, they all threw it once.
Did you see that?
The sequence throwing was crazy.
Oh my gosh.
I think it's stuck.
Oh, my car is, like, not doing so hot.
Nice.
Oops.
Well lit barn!
What's up here anyway?
Why is it so...
What is shaken?
What is shaken bacon?
What's shaken so much?
I think I need to move this car.
And get into the other car.
What is shaking?
New car!
Probably the monster car.
I can't see anything.
I guess we keep going.
Awkward.
Awkward!
Alright.
Excuse me!
It's still shaking, whatever it is.
You guys see that?
Maybe it's supposed to be the way.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
We did it.
Oh, no, my bad.
There we go.
Alan, no clip.
How much?
If I switch to this, 12 bullets over the 8 we have on the
hunting rifle.
I still think the hunting rifle is better though.
Pick up the flare, dummy.
Thank you.
Do we have any more cars or?
Oh, there's one.
There's like, oh, wait.
No.
There are no more cars.
Why?
Maybe if I get rid of the goop.
Come on, please, let me drive.
I reached a checkpoint though.
I do see the flares there.
One second.
Sometimes, oh gosh, it really feels like sometimes that I'm
playing like Eternal Darkness, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm like what in the
Oh shit Oh
Stay away from me Stay away from me
That's right
It feels like my sanity is going crazy And making it so that
I Oh it's just Littered with stuff
Oh Oh my gosh.
Ow, just, ah!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die here.
Wow, Jesus!
That was tough.
Aw, man.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
Wait, let's get this guy.
Oh, I'm too far away, I think.
I don't want to like accidentally run into them, you know?
There we go.
All right, all right, all right.
Modern camping equipment is...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
That's right.
Little babies over there.
Little baby?
Yeah, I don't even need to use two flares on you guys this
time.
That's right.
I don't even need to.
But this part scares me.
I will use the flares instead of the explodees.
Instead of the flashbangs, I think.
Okay.
F4.
AHHHHH!
What the hell you weren't supposed to come yet?
Did they respawn or something or...
Oh shoot.
Ouch!
Please!
Oh my god.
Please.
Let me... Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh geez.
What's happening?
Why is it... Pick up the page.
And run.
Holy cow.
We made it.
Yahoo!
Okay.
And new car.
Yippee!
Jeez, Louise.
I know, right?
They know how to get you in this game.
When will we get to Cauldron Lake?
For real.
Auto salvage and used parts.
Surely I can run through that, right?
We're going to tap it.
Love tap it.
Okay, anyway.
I don't think there was anything important up there.
Oh, wait.
Is that the way I need to go?
It's pointing to the right.
But that's a page.
It's a manuscript page, hold on.
What we're going to do is we're going to
make our getaway.
Alright.
Oh, please.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
If anything comes and gets us after grabbing this.
Okay, nice.
Anyway.
Alright.
We'd have to do that anyway.
Oh, brrrrr.
Trail of the Dark Presence.
The bottom of Calderon Lake was a graveyard of things the
lake had claimed in one way or another over the decades.
Freaky!
The Dark Presence brought them up in its wake.
Scattering the rotten waterlogged hull of an old boat here.
The remains of a long ago crashed airplane there.
Trees shattered under the impacts.
The earth groaned.
It didn't even notice.
Oh!
Wait, what is our...
Wake now knows that he can finish this and rescue Alice.
But first he needs to reach cauldron lake and the cavern
where it all began.
Easy.
Look, I'm taking care of my vehicle.
Is that just fire?
Is that on fire?
Okay.
So why am I going in here now and not to the lake?
Oops.
I said I was taking care of my things.
I meant it.
I have another unread page.
I do.
oh you're right Sarah Barry in the well-lit room in the end
Barry wasn't going to shoot Sarah they both knew that once
she had no chance of catching up to wake Barry gave up the
gun and sat down on the floor shielding his face from the
merciless glare of the well-lit room I don't think I'm ever
gonna see him again he said in a weak voice Sarah didn't
have it in her to be mad at him besides he was probably
right oh he saw That's our best friend!
That's our best friend!
Why am I not at the lake?
I have many questions.
Do I get the checkpoint even in... Okay, I guess not.
Very...
Okay, I did see all of this going on over here.
This looks like an ambush, like for real.
This looks like I'm gonna... wait.
And wouldn't you know I called it?
Wouldn't you know?
Where'd the other guy go?
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Why am I regressing?
Why are my fingers like abandoning me?
I just get it in my head.
Nice.
A lot of good stuff.
That's fine, though.
It's in my nature.
What does that suppose I mean?
It's in my nature to be a screw-up.
Can we, like...
Read.
What's that?
What do you mean, read?
What am I reading?
Oh, this?
All visitors must see the yard manager.
You must sign a liability.
shift hazardous area.
Okay, whatever.
Hmm.
Is there something to open that?
Leave me alone!
Oh, shoot!
There's the manager.
I would like to speak to a manager.
More ammo.
Yippee!
I thought that there would be something to Open the gate.
I guess I could try the gate to see if I, you know, need to
open it or not.
But it's fine getting supplies too, it's good.
There is.
Very nice.
Why does it feel like we've been here before?
Or at least an area that looked very similar to this area.
Okay.
This is like the same exact building layout, and then there
was like a boss down here.
I remember that.
They reuse assets a lot.
It seems like it.
Oh my god.
I leave.
I hear him running.
Anyway.
Planned my escape route perfectly.
Please.
I just want to get to the lake.
I really just want to get to the lake.
Wow!
Okay.
Wow.
That looks not so good.
Where are we supposed to go from here?
Over here?
Maybe?
Oh, it's like swinging.
Whoa!
Um...
Am I supposed to do this?
Minto of the lake.
What is your wisdom?
Oh, there's a page here.
And some flares.
My wisdom is...
Go with friends.
You don't have to do it alone.
Game is charming, but it's very padded with combat.
And they put too many enemies behind you.
I enjoyed Alan Wake 2 a lot more.
Hope you will, too.
I'm glad.
glad that because I guess that would be my quote-unquote
criticism about this game and if two is less like that then
that's good Thomas Zane's last drive Zane cut its heart out
but it didn't die the thing that wore Barbara's face kept
crooning sweet nothings demolition derbing me though he put
on the suit untied the monster from the chair the thing in
his arms thrashed weakly but he held fast he stepped outside
off the pier and into the dark water a sinking pinprick of
light descending toward a bottom that never came she has a
lot of variety oh i'm really glad that's my only thing about
this game is like it feels pretty repetitive it's like i get
to an area uh i get ambushed i get to an area i get ambushed
you know
okay i'm about to be ambushed
What is this anyway?
Okay.
Got
me driving over the five feet to this thing.
No!
Oh
my god, it's hefty.
That's right.
Are there still guys?
I don't know, I can't tell.
My car!
We lost a Vitra rock.
Wait, where am I?
What is opening up anyway?
Like I lost it, whatever it was.
That's just sparks.
Yeah, I don't know where I need to go.
Oh, this opened up, just kidding.
I do know where I need to go.
Run in, run in, run in, run in, run in, run in, run in, run
in, run in.
A new car!
Game is like, here you are, buddy.
We know you destroyed your last one.
All right, on the road.
I just don't understand, I guess, Alan's logic being like,
oh, I have to go through this place to...
Whoa.
Did we go through there?
Wait.
What if we could get the car over there?
I think I also saw a manuscript page.
well i know the road is blocked but it still just seems so
silly
but also the layout of this town is actual hell what if i
need to get to a hospital
like i think everybody might die
can i grab the no okay i think i heard whispers Nope, I
think it's just ambiance.
Just kidding.
No, I think I heard a cat.
What am I hearing?
Oh, there's like so many blinky light things in here.
What's going on?
When I told Barry my plan back in the well-lit room, I'd
acted as if I knew what I was doing.
I didn't.
I was operating on the shifting logic of a dream.
Follow!
I had to fight my way to the lake through the horrors of the
night.
imbued with childhood magic i had to write a happy ending to
a horror story i had to save my wife from the dark prison
she was being held in follow okay why why oh wait what did i
miss revolver ammo where am i supposed to go from here i
don't see i don't see a hole or anything Alan why I this
town is wait hello am I trapped in here how do I get out do
I jump wait wait could you guys tell where I'm supposed to
go I can't see it all oh push yes introduce a new mechanic
at the last chapter of the game Alan push it's a new
mechanic but it's literally just pushing a thing
I think this happened once before okay okay
some weapons yeah I was seeing all of these great love it
Love it.
What am I- oh no, we're using a hunting rifle.
I'll still stick with that I think even.
Okay, here they come.
I see so many blinky things in the- I will never give her to
you.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh Ooh
Oh wait, what happened to me?
What is going on?
I don't know if there's other guys, just in case Oh I think
I need to do this again
Oh shoot You asshole!
You asshole!
Please!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is so unfair.
This is so unfair.
Oh, come on!
If I couldn't use it!
What?
Why would you give me the spotlight if you're gonna have a
guy spawn right next to me?
That was so rude!
Yeah, and now I know not to go next to it.
And then I got like blown into a...
Okay, we'll use the flashbangs for sure.
That was craziness!
Game.
Wait, please.
Pick up the flashbang.
Thank you.
Alright.
Can't trust this game.
I don't!
Why would they do that?
I will never give her to you.
It's so loud.
Don't just... don't focus.
Just run.
We're running.
Please.
Hit.
Oh, I don't think it hit enough.
hit oh i don't oh what the hell was that noise
i don't care if i'm wasting these honestly i don't care
what does that mean oh okay more oh my god they're so
stinking tanky i'm just throwing another one I don't care oh
my god these
guys are the tankiest the flare guns too yeah you're right
you're right well I still have to oh look at that what
there's more what the hell is that sound oh my god you
asshole come over here and fight me it's like it's like a
farting sound zooming past me i guess i could have like
lowered this because previously when i was attempting to use
it um i was able to lower it and like weaken them but it was
just easier throwing all the nades i'm not gonna lie like
the flash bags were so much easier what was that So rude.
So stinking rude.
Come on.
Alan jump.
Alan push.
Oh my god.
You have to B to push and then just spam A.
I need to reload my gun.
Suddenly they're like, hey, don't you want to push all this
stuff?
Uh...
Oh cool, then we're just missing one more.
The dumb place I found myself in was unlike anything I could
ever have imagined.
It wasn't solid.
It was conceptual and subjective.
Solidus.
For someone else, an artist in another field.
It would have been very different.
I could sense the story of the manuscript all around me.
The words and ideas floating in the air, poised to become
real.
Liquid.
No, solidus.
Neither solid nor liquid.
A space in between.
B to push.
Spam A.
Which way do I go?
Oh, probably towards the lion.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
And guys...
If I leave the light...
I guess they like totally despawn.
That's nice.
Andragos!
Thank you so much, I thought I'd get that.
Thank you!
I could see Mirror Peak in the distance.
That's where Calderon Lake was.
Wait, the... the...
Which... the tall mountain?
Or...
Oh my god.
What were you looking at?
Do I go down here?
Oh yes, I do.
Wait, do I get to ride this?
Now let's jump!
Wait, what just happened?
Okay, hold on.
Yes!
This is fine.
And very slow.
It's so peaceful.
I see the birds.
Kind of hard, though.
Oh,
my god.
We barely made it.
I'm kind of like, is this chapter mostly going to be getting
to the lake?
If only we had a helicopter or some friends, some nice
company.
We made it!
It is entirely getting to the lake.
Don't tell me that.
No way.
Entirely?
Oh my gosh, am I going to be pushing this thing and then
also trying to fight off the birds?
I hate when I'm right.
You know, the gift of prophecy, at least, oh, maybe we're
fine.
They call it a gift, but it's quite often a curse.
Oh, no.
Alan jump
Where'd you go?
That was close I was hoping that maybe my battery would
charge enough before they flew back at me but no i don't
cinematic very allans don't belong in a lash oh
i love the music the music kills me it's so funny
i'd rather fight birds the entire time than the guys though
i'm not gonna lie give me birds all the way I'm the rest of
my way there.
Please, I don't want to fight anymore, man.
So tired.
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, stay away.
Where'd you go?
Wait, I said stay away, but come back.
Oh, I shall...
Get him in the legs, get him in the legs.
Oh shoot.
Where the hell?
Screw it.
Oh shoot.
Why is it in slow though?
Okay.
Sick.
Cinema.
Get ragdolled!
Oh, please have hunting rifle.
No.
This revolver ammo.
I'll still take it.
I often forget about the flare gun.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm sure you can tell, but it's great when I use it.
Okay, so we're going to the lift.
Anything else around?
I keep thinking I'm seeing sparkles, you know.
La la la.
So much better in this game than in two.
I mean, I have a lot of ammo for it.
I should use it.
La la la.
To the lake.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Yeah!
Why am I getting you through the tree?
I'm
hiding behind the tree!
Did I just go run?
He's hiding.
Scary cat, baby.
Can't wait to be ambushed here, too.
Oh my gosh.
Holy shit.
Please.
Oh my god.
Wait, no.
Okay.
Now I can start this.
Jeez, Louise.
Yeah, I heard them coming too.
That's why I was like, I'm about to get ambushed by some
guys.
I know.
I know this game now.
This way?
What's up here?
Nothing?
Okay.
You can see, like, the parts that were, like, you know how
it describes the inside of the lake as, like, having all
the...
Another!
Like, all this stuff.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
Oh, oh.
No, I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
You saw the rock?
She's stuck?
He's...
Who's he doing?
Oh,
I missed.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that scared the heck out of me.
That scared me so much!
Oh my god!
Where'd he go?
I see you.
Thermus.
Grab it.
Grab it?
Oh, there's a guy there.
I'm gonna run out of flares at this rate.
Oh man.
Ah!
There's so many of them!
Oh shoot.
Oh shoot!
Yeah!
Late epic shot.
Where is he anyway?
Where is he?
Oh!
There's more stuff in here.
Flashbangs!
Thank you.
Itadakimasu!
I feel like I'm actually like kind of running out of flares
though.
I know that game like usually gives you so many, but I'm
like...
Um, I don't know.
Kind of scared.
Am I going the right way?
Seems like it.
Ah!
Holy shit!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Oh shoot.
That was so cool!
Please, don't...
Please.
Okay.
Holy cow!
Alright.
I thought I heard somebody.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Alright.
Your Honor, she's gaming.
I didn't even do anything.
I think.
What was that?
Oh.
We just keep going.
Just what I was about to say.
Oh crap indeed!
Stop with the slow-mos, please!
Just stay on the edge.
I think I'm okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe I'm not okay.
It's a barrel.
Ouch!
Oh, what was that?
No, wait.
Oh, I think it's the goop.
It's whatever.
I run.
I do not see.
I do not care.
Haunted.
Yeah.
I'll clean up anyway.
Because I'm a good Samaritan.
No litter, no litter.
Even if it's a spooky, goopy haunted litter.
Oh, get to Cauldron Lake, they said.
This is like suggesting to go to Silent Hill for like
vacation.
Who would do that?
Where even are we?
Is this the historical site?
Like what?
What is this place?
What are you saying?
The darkness wears her face.
I know!
I get it!
My god!
I have so much shotgun ammo.
I feel like I should just use the shotgun for a bit now.
Hmm.
to my hunting rifle.
Was I out of rifle shells?
I thought I had like eight or something.
The darkness controls the dragon.
Alright, over here, right?
Okay, good.
I'm like just looking around.
I'm scoping the place out before we... Oh my gosh.
There's like buttons everywhere.
This place is huge.
Oh no!
see what i need to do i need to press it so that i can bring
the thing over and ride it oh man this is gonna wait how do
i how do i get back in here oh okay calm down alan calm down
how do i get back in here once i leave though besides alan
just doesn't wait does this open up no it's not a gate
I'm trying to like plan my route before I go through.
Alan could just bend out.
Alan has the worst knees in histories.
You don't.
But am I not driving that?
Preemptive flare gun at the ready?
Huh.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
They give you so much stuff.
What is he doing?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I missed.
Come on.
Can you guys, like, stay close?
Oh shoot, uh, Flare?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
I wish I could see anything right now.
Where are you?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
That was so stinking close.
Uh, he's like, camping me?
I wish I had my hunting rifle right now.
Okay, I think I took care of them for now.
Honestly, with those guys running around, it's easier to
just, like, kind of wait for them.
I hear somebody.
Wee!
Why is everything in this game so slow?
Oh, okay.
I don't even feel like looking around.
Just give me to the like.
Oh, I think that's our last page!
Awesome!
Oh, I was worried that I might miss it.
Nice.
Yes!
Right?
If it doesn't scroll down, yeah.
After Zane had gone, I stood alone in the shifting dream
that was the dark place.
I had to find a way to the cabin.
I had written myself a way through this place in the
manuscript.
I followed the idea of a path.
I had written myself across the ocean that blocked my way,
and with that, there was a bridge to the island beyond.
The idea of the cabin flickered in the underwater darkness.
I willed the cabin to be real, and it was.
The idea of a path.
I'm getting like Looney Tunes vibes where you know like...
Where like...
Wildy Coyote will paint a road...
Like a... Like a road on the wall.
And Roadrunner will run down it.
And it's just...
Okay.
Nice.
We just gotta think.
And it will happen.
I guess.
Oh.
Oh, thank goodness.
All right.
Are we almost there?
Turn back now.
Oh, oh, it's a magnet.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Please.
There we go.
Oh, awkward.
Oh, oh, shoot.
I have the wrong weapon.
Holy cow.
Why are you so strong now?
Shouldn't my shotgun, like, do more than just that?
Allen dodge.
Okay, we got rid of that.
Um, what if I do this?
Hey, yeah.
Did
that?
that do anything?
You were spoiled by the rifle.
I truly was.
I think I hear somebody.
What?
Stop it!
Go away!
Nice spot.
What if we hit flare gun?
Oh.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh my god, wait, there's rocks.
Oh my god, what am I supposed to do about the rocks?
Why this game's so flashy.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, is this my thumbnail?
Oh my god.
Why would you say that?
What does that have to do with anything?
I think she liked me very much, maybe.
Am I getting it from here?
Oh, wait!
Oh, my God!
Holy cow!
That was so close!
Alan, dodge, but do it better.
Dodge!
Oh, wait.
Is that a thermos?
No.
Just will the house into existence!
You can do it!
Checkpoint!
Nice.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Can't see anything.
I'm going!
Oh!
By bad.
I
didn't know that there was a...
Destroy the tornado!
Oh.
Wee!
Woo!
Ow!
No I won't!
Shoot!
Oh, okay, that didn't do much.
Uh, how else do you want me to do this?
Uh, this one!
Nice!
Almost?
See that at the end of it?
You want these parts too?
Okay.
Ammo box?
Where?
Woo!
My goodness.
Um, okay.
Follow the boat.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh, stop doing that please!
Uh...
There we go.
I had to get light into it's hard to hurt it.
Bill is hard with light.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like I almost about to fall.
Holy cow.
Not that one.
There we go.
Oh.
Jump into it.
I don't think so.
Maybe?
I don't know, actually.
Alan.
Do
not jump into it.
Are you sure?
Because...
I feel like it's just that one piece that I can't get.
Oh my gosh, it's moving so fast.
Oh, that one.
There's an ammo box?
Is there really?
I don't...
Oh!
Can I jump that way?
I don't think I can.
Oh, I can, I can.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh...
Oh, shoot.
Maybe...
Like, hit.
Ah!
Times it, like, targets on.
I don't think I got him.
Oh, those arms all over the...
Wow.
It did say the heart.
Maybe I got all that I can shoot at around it.
Let's see.
The flare gun was the only way to get right into the heart
of the gun.
Oh, yeah, baby!
It's all in your head.
Oh, birds, birds, birds!
Oh, sweet.
is a lot i know i kept thinking kick of hearts too oh my
gosh if you guys haven't told me about the i was just
jumping to get to the edge i didn't even see the ammo box at
all nice oh is it clicker time
time to click yeah baby oh my gosh it's all clicking see why
don't don't hold it like that over the edge you're gonna
drop it alan wake don't oh Oh
So good Allin allin jump scare
Baby you were having a bad dream It was just another
nightmare No Everything's fine.
You're home.
No, we're not.
It wasn't a dream.
Everything's fine.
Turn the lights on Turn the lights on!
Shh, baby.
The power's out.
There's no light.
Come back to bed and I'll make you forget all about your
fear in the dark.
You will?
My fear?
It's your fear.
Why aren't you afraid?
You're not Alice.
Turn the lights on now.
Where's the clicker?
What did you do with it?
Alan, honey, you're still one dream.
Oh, you're not making any sense.
Come back to bed.
Find the clicker.
Okay.
Is it in here?
Is it in our tiny washing machine?
Clicker.
Ouch!
Wait, what just hurt me?
Would the word clicker hurt me?
Oh my gosh!
It's him!
Clicker injury.
You must find your way to the cabin.
He stands in your way.
It won't let you pass.
Big daddy.
Big Zane.
He's filled with darkness.
You must fill his heart with light.
I'll fill his heart with light!
Oh.
Cooler me.
Don't mind him.
He's Mr. Scott.
Your friends will meet him when you're gone.
Don't mind him?
What do you mean by that?
Don't mind that guy.
The evil clone of you?
Yeah.
Whoa!
What is happening?
Oh, okay, now I can move.
Get rid- oh, I hate text!
Goodbye text, goodbye- oh bird!
I don't know- oh- oh!
Ask and you shall receive.
Wait, this is so fun!
Hello!
I followed the idea of a path.
A path!
What's in the shopping cart?
Domestic Allen.
What's this one?
What does that say?
Lighting pole?
Talking?
What is this?
Some sort of pole?
Oh, okay.
I followed the idea of a path.
It's revealed to me!
Oh.
Moshi Moshi.
Oh, shut up.
Bridge.
I'm leaving you.
What?
I'm leaving you, Alan.
I met someone.
I'm in love with someone else.
Super chat.
You don't love me.
How could you?
I wouldn't even love yourself.
All you do is torture yourself with work you can't do
anymore.
What's in the shoebox?
you're you're my muse you're my muse who are you what have
you done with my Alice Alan what are you doing put the light
back on what are you it wasn't true nothing like that had
ever happened oh do we want my Barbara Tom I promised to be
good freaky oh my gosh a time you naughty boy I will love
you forever no you're not I want the bird or the leg or the
cabin.
Let's go for the leg.
You came back wrong.
Your heart is filled with darkness.
Bird.
Filled.
You hag!
Don't call Matara that.
Your husband refused to do as you was told all they had to
do was write what i wanted him to write now it's too late
it's his fault you'll stay here forever the done oh my god
this part's so funny now you will never get her back why why
I am much older than you.
Yeah, I know.
Older than your first work of art.
What does that have to do with it?
I will find a new face to wear.
Ah, someone else to dream me free.
I...
Oh!
She hasn't been embraced like that in a long time.
Good clicker!
Oh,
Bill's with the line.
Yeah, get clicked.
Yeah!
Get clicked!
Elbozo!
Alan Hug was too much for her.
Alan Hug!
I
could feel Alice's presence close by.
I understood what I had to do now.
What happens when you turn 30?
I knew how to write the ending to departure.
Yeah, you're like...
There's light and there's darkness.
I am older than you.
cause and effect.
There's guilt and there's atonement.
But the scales always need to balance.
Everything has a price.
That's where Zane had gone wrong.
There's a long journey through the night back into the
light.
Eight months old is technically hag territory for roaches.
Alice?
What happened to the FBI guy?
Did he die?
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
A million hours.
That's what it felt like playing this game.
No, just kidding.
My guy is constantly diving into water.
My guy is constantly just doing the most.
I think we should just get rid of the whole town.
Alice!
She swam!
Oh my god, that's what we wrote.
She swam really hard.
She swam good.
Actually, she was an Olympic swimmer.
So she could swim a lot.
I'm literally, that's what he's typing right now.
Oh my gosh, we got Alice back.
That's crazy.
Wait, did he sacrifice himself though?
So Alice is alive, but he's...
Alan?
In the cabin?
Oh, no.
Balancing the scales, he said.
Oh, he was like, as long as she's alive, it's okay.
Zane wanted them to be together.
Flame, welcome to Babusha.
Thank you.
Alan, save.
Alan will never wake.
He'll never get breakfast.
No!
And Alice swam real good and beat the bad guy.
And then it never turned night ever again.
Because she was scared of dark.
Welcome to Bright Falls.
Alice swam good.
Wife and arms, spooch, smooch.
Oh!
Dear Festival is happening!
Oh my gosh, there's more than...
Wow!
We killed, like, half the population, but...
There's still 20 people left!
How is this heart with three sizes that day?
Oh!
The brothers!
They made it!
Oh!
Oh.
Wait, who is in this?
a window oh wait she's the new huh g-man she's the new
Cynthia yeah it's an ocean
whoa yeah that was the F that was nightingale only
took us 13 freaking years to follow this up wait is this the
song I it is ground control to major tom wow oh dmca for
real ground control to major tom i'll turn it off for you
guys sorry because i don't i want to hear it 10 9 8 7.
can't believe sam lake stole original credits the end gs3
how did they get this song and not metal gear and may god be
with you here i'll do the karaoke of it
this is made to troll the magic top i don't remember the
next
First want to know whose shirts you wear It's time to leave
the capsule Capsule if you dare I don't remember the words
This is Major Tom to Ground Control I'm stepping through the
In the most peculiar way Stars look very different today or
here am i the tin cad
planet earth is blue and there's nothing i can do bing bing
bing bing cut cut bing bing bing bing bing
minky is green and there's nothing i can do this i've
crossed on hundred thousand miles i'm feeling very still
ships there's a way to go tell my wife i love her very much
she knows
Tom there your circuits dead there's something wrong can you
hear me major Tom can you hear me major Tom can you hear me
major Tom can you hear and I floating in my tank and far
above the world this song is so great man earth is blue and
there's nothing i can do
full karaoke cover please okay wait ah i wish i had a way to
do it i'll do i'll redo it i'll redo this after thank you
guys for the super chats thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you
And fade out.
It's not a lake.
It's an ocean.
Yeah!
Oh, thank you for the flower.
Thank you.
Minky is too cute.
And there's nothing I can do.
Don't worry, guys.
I know that I played.
Alan Wake 1 to get to Alan Wake 2, but I was fully informed
of playing control in between this and Alan Wake, so I, and
Alan Wake 2, I mean, so I do plan on playing it like that,
so don't worry, don't worry, fully informed, yes, by the
many people in chat that told me.
So yeah, yeah, yeah.
American Nightmare, we'll see if I want to, I kind of want
to just, like, that's not a mainline game, like, main story
game, right?
So, I kind of want to just, like, play the, I want to get to
Alan Wake 2.
Maybe we'll see it after Alan Wake 2.
It's not canon, yeah.
I, I, I originally started this because I was like, man,
I've heard such good things about Alan Wake 2.
I want to know the hype.
So...
Oh my gosh, Sam Lake!
He...
He was next to Alan Wake!
Did he do that on purpose?
Wait, Minto, did you know the darkness wears her face?
No!
Also, if you told me that...
That...
Don't trust anyone in the dark, I would be shocked.
I don't...
I...
I don't even know.
Do you trust anyone that are?
Never, never, never.
100 on purpose.
Halo Infinite actually is next chronologically.
Oh, well, I cancel my stream tomorrow.
We're going to play Halo Infinite.
It's not a Sam Lake.
It's a Sam Ocean.
Then the SpongeBob...
The SpongeBob...
SpongeBob movie.
Big pants.
Big guy.
Which SpongeBob movie?
The newest one?
Because if so, oof.
We might skip.
Spang baby.
I can't believe.
Wait, so.
If Rose becomes the new Cynthia, what happened to Cynthia?
What happened to Barry?
Barry.
Wait.
Did they ever leave the room?
The well-lit room?
DLC answers?
Okay, good.
She got clicked.
Did she disappear because of...
Anyone that knew of Zane, did they all have to disappear?
Whoa, my goodness!
Look at their multiple...
Wow!
Talented people!
Playing so many roles.
Night Springs narrator.
Wow.
Taken.
Night Springs man number one.
Deputy.
Night Springs dreamer.
Taken.
I would...
Oh my gosh.
I would love to play one of the Taken in this game.
What kind of line would you want to say?
They're so funny.
I'm not...
I want to say a taken line.
Do you think you'll still call him Alan Wick?
I don't think so.
Because I got so used to being like, Alan jump.
You know, Alan wake up.
I think I get it now.
I think I'm okay.
I think I'm cured.
John Wick, Alan Wake.
I know the difference.
I know.
That was my controller.
I know the difference.
Character development.
I...
Maybe that would be my line in Alan Wake.
And be like, Have you watched critically acclaimed John Wick
movie?
You know, there were no girl taken.
Now that I think about it.
American Nightmare answers what happens to Barry, but I
thought it wasn't canon.
Congrats on being cured.
Thank you!
Yeah.
There were no girl taken.
Your line wouldn't be Metal Gear related.
How could we make it Metal Gear related?
Alan Wake's journey through the night will continue!
Oh my god!
Unable to log into Epic Online Services, please check your
connection and restart.
Did you finish John Wake?
I only watched the first one.
Wait, I kind of want to watch this again and see what we
recognize now.
I saved my wife Hot dog Hot dog indeed Or save it Oh Yeah
that part was kind of poopy Stupid FBI guy Thanks for coming
up On up to Deerfest Hope we can make it back for the next
fest I don't think I ever want to go to the PNW Because I
I'm just going to fear this game.
I'm going to be so scared of running around in the forest.
Forever and ever and ever.
Do you all see you next week?
Maybe next week.
Maybe, maybe.
There are only like four women in the entire town.
So yeah, I'm not shocked by the lack of Taken ladies.
You know what?
That's so fair.
All the Taken guys were like at...
you know what also all the guys that were taken were the
zane is so funny where ever it seemed like they were taken
at work most of the time like you had like the lumberjacks
and you had you had your uh you had your uh guys at the
power plant but minke think of the deer
is canon but it's a side story think of it to mgr to mgs
okay well i'll still think about it i'll still think about
it how much more alan wake i can take no taking women so
there's a lot of single ladies oh yeah guys head to bright
falls because i killed every almost there's like 20 men left
i killed everybody else and so all the men were taken wait
no The women are not taken.
Alan take.
I taketh.
And that's about it.
Yeah, I keepeth.
I am Alan Wake.
And I writeeth.
This game is so wackadoodle, it's so funny.
It's like just...
What's so funny about it is it...
I don't want to say it completely takes itself seriously,
because it doesn't.
But it's so like...
It's so funny in that it'll be like, Oh no, my...
Oh, whoops.
My girlfriend.
Or my wife is gone.
Yeah, it plays it straight, even though it's so silly.
It's so fun.
It's so, so funny.
This is my kind of game.
I had so much fun.
Oh, dude.
Here, we're gonna skip.
We're gonna move.
We're gonna move over.
We can chat for a little bit before I...
I was fully prepared.
I thought at least, like, another hour or so.
Awesome.
Cool, cool, cool.
Uh, actually?
Is this gonna work?
Where the heck is the desk?
What?
Oh, there it is.
My scenes are all messed up recently.
Where's the table?
Where am I?
Oh, I went down, that's right.
I went below.
Yay!
Let me put on some music.
Wait, hold on.
Let's quit the game.
Wait, what's the extras?
What are my stats?
Wait!
I want to see my stats.
Wait, hold on.
Where's the game?
The game?
Oh, guys.
Guys, killed with the revolver.
149.
It's like a Pokemon.
At least 150.
One more to see.
I killed 800 birds.
I found 72 out of 100 thermoses.
Wait, I still missed so many chests also.
I missed a radiant...
Wait.
I wonder if it counts the one that I didn't turn on, even
though I had turned it on before.
There were cardboard standees and alarm clocks.
Night Springs video games.
What the...
Wait, signs found.
What does that mean?
Oh, like the things I could read maybe?
Indirect kill 65.
No, they were all on purpose.
Poltergeist objects destroyed.
240 batteries.
Kills with flashbangs, kills with vehicles.
I didn't even know that you could find standees or alarm
clocks or video games.
What the heck?
The last items are from the DLC.
Oh, that makes sense.
Playback.
Oh, fine.
David Bowie's Space Oddity.
Let's go sing Space Oddity.
Let's go sing it.
Karaoke time.
Since you guys didn't get to hear it at all.
You guys didn't get to hear it.
Round control to Major Tom.
vocal ground control to major Tom take your protein pills
and put your helmet on ground control to major Tom
commencing countdown engines on
Check ignition and may God's love be with you.
This is ground control to Major Tom.
You've really made the grave.
And the papers want to know whose shirts you wear.
Now it's time to leave the capsule if you dare This is Major
Tom to ground control I'm stepping through the door And I'm
floating in a most peculiar way And the stars look very
different Today For here Am I sitting in a tin can Far above
the world Planet Earth is blue And there's nothing I can do
BAMB
Though I'm thinking past 100,000 miles.
I'm feeling very still.
And I think my spaceship knows which way to go.
Tell my wife I love her very much.
She knows!
Ground control to major time your circuit's dead.
There's something wrong.
Can you hear me, Major Tom?
Can you hear?
Am I floating around my tin can Far above the moon The
planet's earth is blue And there's nothing I can do
So good!
Since you guys didn't get to hear it in the credits!
I love this song so much, it's so good!
Wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee!
Do you guys have any plans for this weekend?
Anything you're planning on doing?
Anything you got going on?
I was never a Bowie fan until I listened with you.
What do you mean?
I'm in space.
You are in space.
Building gumball fun.
Chilling.
Work, unfortunately.
No, you're sick and bad.
Feel better.
Beam.
Hey, Ximinto, that was beautiful.
Of course.
Let me see, um...
Uh, what's this one?
Resident Evil Marathon before the new game.
Wait, when does the new game come out?
Did they announce it?
Thank you, Minto.
Thank you!
Iron Lung.
I want to go see it.
I heard that it has like practical effects and stuff and
that it's...
February 27th!
Wow, that's so soon!
Oh my gosh.
I had no idea it was so soon.
That's exciting.
I kind of wish that I did a that I did a that I caught up,
you know.
The Markiplier one.
My mom bought me a streaming ticket for your jazz concert.
Thank you, mom.
The mortuary assistant is also are releasing on the 13th.
Game?
Movie?
Wasn't there there was an AirDorf movie?
They made a movie!
Wait, I must go see it!
Wait, hold on.
Mortuary Assistant.
I loved that game.
Wait, there's a... Wait, can we watch the movie trailer?
Wait, let's watch the movie trailer together.
It might be kind of spooky, though.
Are you guys okay with that?
Oh, whoa, whoa, hold on, hold on.
It put me in like a...
Yeah, okay, hold on.
Resident Evil Marathon and my life is yours.
Oh, what joy is this?
Oh, this works.
It's like, put me in.
There we go, hold on.
There we go.
I'll put it below me.
I had no idea about this.
This game really spooks me.
I love on Beyond's games more than anything, you know?
So, um...
You got room in this chair?
Okay, I'm...
It worked.
Scoot, scoot, scoot, scoot over.
Scoot, scoot, scoot over.
Big buttoot hog in the whole thing.
Okay, let's uh, where'd I put the, wait, where'd the,
where'd the window go?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
All right.
Three, two, one.
All right, Mr. Leibowitz.
Let's get you en-bombed and I guess- She said shutter.
So is it on the shutter?
Terrifier!
Oh no, is it going to be boring?
Slapface.
is somebody there I know what you experienced was terrifying
but you need to listen to me if you want to survive the
entity will do anything to gain control oh my god I remember
this part oh my god I want this to stop Please!
To banish a demon to hell.
Oh my gosh.
You need to learn its name.
Oh!
Do I have something that you wish?
I wonder what ending they'll go for.
You need to get off the phone.
You have to help me.
Oh my gosh, that's that guy!
That's me.
The demon knows everything about you.
So what do we do?
It looks fine.
Oh my gosh, I'm like recognizing everything.
I'm like the houses of hell.
I command you back.
Okay, I don't remember that.
Ew.
Oh.
It's pretty icky.
The possessed ending is most likely.
You think so?
It's actually in theaters.
What?
Wait, I'm the 13th.
Oh my gosh, Valentine.
Wait, that's one of my shows.
show is i could go the day after oh two weeks ago this
trailer came out huh oh my gosh i want to go see the night
of your show okay guys wait change of plans i know i have i
know i wait wait okay we we we go watch the movie first and
then we all head to the jazz show together
Don't show canceled.
Don't want to do that.
We go watch.
Surely it's not going to come out at night.
That's not how movies work.
They have a daytime showing, too.
Oh, scary.
Oh, that game really freaks me out.
I hope it's anything.
It looks...
I don't know.
The trailer makes it seem like...
It's always those kind of trailers that make it seem like
more.
more action-y, you know, than how the original was.
Do you scream in the theater?
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I don't know the last time I went and saw a horror movie in
the theater.
Have you seen the autopsy of Jane Doe?
Uh, yes, once a long time ago.
The true horror.
Hundreds of eyeballs descending on a single unsuspecting
theater.
I'm wondering, honestly, how well this movie is going to
perform.
Because I haven't heard anything about it.
Maybe I just haven't seen anything, but...
That's the scariest part.
Iron Lung is doing great.
Yeah!
I heard that Markiplier even said that he made a profit
before the movie came out, which is kind of crazy.
How?
I don't know.
Maybe pre-order tickets?
I don't know how it works, to be honest.
I honestly don't know.
A singular prophet.
I heard, though, it was pretty good.
Like, I saw, I've seen reviews from people that played the
game and also like Markiplier, and then I've seen reviews
from people that know of Markiplier and are, like, more
movie people and don't know the source material, which I
honestly think, those kinds of reviews are more valuable
than someone that does know the source material because as
much as I love like a fan service you know you gotta make it
you gotta make it digestible to everybody you know you can't
just have me being pointing at the screen the whole time
being like I get it I know that reference you know but yeah
it's gotta be good on the cord yeah yeah yeah so i as from
the from the reviews of people that don't know the game they
kind of were like they liked it they said it was good just
that there were some parts that were kind of confusing so
like what was expected of the minecraft movie
you don't like fan service for the most part i kind of love
fan service i'm not gonna lie a time and place like say it
depends on how it's marketed you know like if it's marketed
to fans then it's it's i think it's okay but if it's like hi
hi come check out my movie then
then yeah I think it's like well I get it but you know you
want people to like the thing that you like so that you can
get more of the thing that you like you know what I mean
that's just the truth of the matter that's just the truth of
the matter but yeah it's very cool we've been getting well i
was about to say we've been getting like all these video
game actually we've been getting all these like horror game
movie adaptations but i did you guys hear the reviews on the
silent i don't want to speak because i don't want karnami to
hear me
There's like, there was one Big change in the movie that
makes me It changes the story so much That it like Upsets me
to a To A crazy degree
I'm always like torn on like adaptations of video games
because I understand when people say well you've played if
you want the original story of the game play the game you've
seen the story of the game we're kind of changing it up a
little bit you know what I mean Yeah, the director did not
understand the game at all.
I know.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
It's rise.
It's it's been it's been driving me crazy the past couple of
days.
But anyway.
Like I understand when people are like, yeah, we're doing
like the same story, but kind of our own rendition of it.
I get it.
I understand that mentality.
is it my favorite mentality not quite like i i understand it
but i'm always just like yeah but if you it's kind of like
with the disney live action remakes you know like how
they've been changing so many like they'll be like oh this
this uh we're doing a live action of snow white but we're
giving so and so a backstory and it's like what like the
thing about it is if you do a different okay so people like
the original right if you do something different there's not
there's always a chance that people are not gonna like it
you know what i mean so it's just kind of like you're it
almost feels like you're damned if you do damned if you
don't because if you make a faithful true adaptation then
people are like well i'm just gonna play the
Yeah, it's just...
Yeah, if you like Silent Hill 2, I heard that the
cinematography is really good.
That it has some cool shots in it.
Isn't the point to show the work to non-gamers?
I'm talking about adaptations all around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not just gaming, game.
Because, I mean, you have adaptations of anime and stuff,
too.
What was that?
There was, like, that one movie with Tom Cruise in it.
The one where he keeps dying and being reborn.
That's an adaptation of an anime.
Or a manga?
Edge of Tomorrow!
Yes, yes, yes.
It's, uh...
Edge of tomorrow.
I liked the movie.
I liked that movie.
All you need is kill is that anime, I believe.
Right?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I like the movie.
I don't know anything about all you need is kill.
But I like the movie.
I did like the movie.
Yeah.
Movie was good.
There's a new anime movie for that too.
is i saw it recently the animation looks really interesting
yeah yeah yeah so see like that's a i guess a good example
but also at the same time i feel like nobody would know that
it is based off of a manga
getting an anime but fairly different visuals yeah egypt
tomorrow was nothing like the original
but you know you just can't the truth of the matter is too
you can't make everybody happy that's just that's just how
it goes you can't make everybody happy and that's why it's
nice that if a media comes out of something that you really
like be it a movie adaptation or whatever if you don't like
it you can ignore it and you can play the game and say wow I
like the game if you don't like something ignore it you'll
be much happier
ignoring yeah
what if we like VTuber named the made me channel don't
ignore don't ignore game bunga bunga yeah yeah yeah yeah
pretend not to see it's like oh i love i love thing it's so
great that thing exists and we don't talk about other stuff
a scene with the gravestone though oh in silent hills oh i
would give you guys spoilers but i i don't you know
did you watch it silent hill no no no no no i didn't and
that's okay i especially it was very weary i mean a lot of
people were from the trailers alone a lot of people were
like oh pull that collar i don't know about this one
But...
Yeah.
Have you guys seen that?
You know what?
It's kind of funny because before...
Before Silent Hill 2 remake, I don't think...
Because I heard so many good things about it.
Obviously, I haven't played it myself.
But before that, I wouldn't have been excited about a new
Bluebird team game.
But did you see that they were teasing something?
A lot of people think it's Rule of Rose, which would be very
interesting if it is.
Very, very interesting.
Rule of Rose is wild.
It would be quite...
You know what, though?
I often confuse elements of Rule of Rose and Haunting
Ground.
Like, they're so...
Because there's, like, the dog.
Like, sometimes I'll be like, oh, yeah, that's monster.
And I'll be like, no, that's Haunting Ground, not Rule of
Rose.
Hmm.
both feature a girl with a dog they're remaking the first
silent hill aren't they they did announce that they were
doing that so but i don't i don't know if that's i wonder if
they would do a countdown for especially like it was like a
17 day countdown for the remake of silent hill one something
that they've already announced i feel like they i feel like
either a new uh i think it's a new property or something
content ground is called demento in japanese whoa i didn't
know that actually i didn't know that they're making
something with nintendo too oh really oh you know what oh my
gosh please eternal darkness remake you know what i would i
would do it i would I would play it all over again.
I mean, I have to play it again to get the other ending, so.
Because imagine, like, the sanity effects they could do,
like, modern day.
Paragon, paragon, paragon.
Parodius.
Yeah, it'd be pretty fun.
Paragon, paragon, paragon.
Peace Walker Portal.
on Switch?
We gotta get...
I think, well, definitely Master Collection Part 2 will have
Peace Walker port, for sure.
They can't not.
House have Peace Walker.
And hopefully 4.
Hopefully that's what we're waiting on.
Opens up your system file.
Oh my gosh.
People will play...
Oh no.
People will play Eternal Darkness if it got remade and be
like, Is this Doki Doki Literature Club...
Is this Doki Doki Literature Club RPG?
No, no, don't say that.
Oh.
Who even owns the Eternal Darkness IP?
It's a great question.
I know the sanity thing is copyrighted, so that's why it's
like...
Will you play the final?
Oh, final.
Oh my gosh.
Fatal Frame 2 remake.
Absolutely.
Yes, I will.
Yes, yes, yes.
First horror game was Doki Doki Literature Club.
I know.
Final.
frame you oh nintendo does own it okay okay
fatal frame is called project zero in the eu for some reason
i think that's because it's closer to the to the uh japanese
name but maybe sometimes they do that because like it's too
close i i wonder if like project zero is too close to
another copyright
or it could be that they were like oh project zero doesn't i
don't know sometimes they just change things to kind of feel
like it'll appeal to more people yeah like resident evil
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah biohazard biohazard
i don't know i i feel like the name resident evil is so
Like, I can't think of another...
You know, I couldn't think of it as a biohazard.
It made a name for itself.
Resident Evil.
I always think of, like...
No, I think of...
I'm kind of thinking...
I'm saying Resident Evil with, like, the House of the
Dead...
Like, the guy that says House of the Dead on the...
What's the word?
The Arcade.
game when it goes house of the dead i think resident evil
you know but it's so iconic house of the dead these games
are so fine resident evil used to have that too oh it did
maybe that's why i'm thinking of it also that's how they say
it in the games too oh maybe i am thinking of it then
resident of the house of House of the Evil Dead Residents.
Very memorable title screens.
Bring them back.
Another one that I like to say is on the 3D...
Not 3D.
On the...
Yeah, 3DS.
Was it Rune Factory 4?
An old roommate.
I had it on the 3DS and so they would just be like, Rude
Factory 4.
I'm sure you already brought this up.
I'm sure somebody already brought this up.
I don't know if you'll play it, but did you see the
potentially...
Yeah, the Solid Snake and Rainbow Six Siege I did.
The trailer was pretty cool.
Having the codec come up, specifically MGS2 codec, and then
like the smoke all around him, it looked really good.
It looks pretty cool.
But I've never played that game.
It's like just a shooter, isn't it?
It's just...
You know, I was able...
I was tempted to get the...
Like, I was tempted...
Rather, I was convinced to get the Fortnite skins.
But I don't know if I'll do this.
you would be in hell I'd be like Anu Ectol please be nice to
me I may be like Shut up Shut up stupid baby Except they
would Say something Much worse to me
It would be Something I would have to beat maybe
Something I would have to Something I would have to censor
from the stream.
Unless I get to my channel, take it away from me.
Game has issue with players vote kicking for no reason.
They're just, you're just, no, it's the vibes.
It's the vibes.
You don't pass the vibe check.
Resident Evil is to me like MGSSCO.
It's my biggest special interest of all time.
If you need a place to start Resident Evil 2, remake is the
best.
Thank you!
I have been wanting to start the Resident Evil journey
lately.
There's just too many series that I want to do.
Not enough time.
I feel like I need to like...
Do like, okay guys, we're starting this series, the game,
whole week.
But it's hard.
the first world problems.
I know.
And with you, I'm winning an eternal darkness remaster, a
good remake.
I love that game to death and it's been horribly neglected.
It just sucks.
It's stuck on the GameCube.
You know, like...
That's the worst feeling is when a game is stuck on an old
console.
Dark Souls?
I've already saw Ace Combat ahead of you, and it's crazy how
cool the games feel from the very first one.
I think, I don't know, I'm very, like, with my schedule how
it is, I'm so, like, when do I get to Ace Combat?
And also, even before Ace Combat 8.
Vicky for help.
What on Dark Souls?
We did think about doing a Night Reign, Densetsu, Trio.
Too many good games.
I know, I know.
That would be chaos.
That'd be hilarious.
Two very differing thoughts on the matter.
Nah, I don't know the...
stories are so different you can play eight without
finishing the others it won't matter i know but like by
principle i've i've been collecting them so that i can play
them you know i just enjoyed seven so much like i just i
really really liked seven and i especially want to play from
the beginning because obviously it's been a really long time
since i played seven i thought about even going back in my
free time and just kind of getting back into the controls of
it the dog fighting of it all um so yeah re7 no no sorry not
resident evil ace combat ace combat seven
uh mito is a series appreciator yeah i i just really liked
seven so i want to like go through that i don't want to
understand the board everything more about the the countries
and stuff so yeah
also check out project wingman yeah I've been told that but
one step at a time one step at a time first anyways guys I'm
getting hungry so I'm gonna I'm gonna head out now thank you
for hanging out with me i had so much fun oh my gosh we beat
it alan wake woohoo thank you thank you thank you guys thank
you thank you thank you let's see is anybody streaming we
can read into phoebe is doing a video game karaoke so we
shall if you want to hear more karaoke you can stick around
for phoebe
Look at the pink!
Wait, one second, one second, one second.
Faye, faye boy, faye boy, faye boy.
Oh my god, talk shouts.
Faye, faye...
Faye boy, faye...
How do you spell faye boy, faye, p-h...
Faye...
Oh...
Uh...
Oh, there's you.
Okay.
Woo!
Thanks for all the cute noises, Minto.
What did I do?
What noises?
Minto ended the stream and smiled in triumph.
No more Alan bad knees.
No more taken with their ambushes and with fart-sounding
axes.
Why did they suddenly start sounding like that?
But the game done, Minto, was left to write out the rest of
her night.
And she wrote herself a fantastic one.
Aww!
All the well, that ends well, huh?
Thanks again for playing Alan Wake, Minto.
Thank you!
Thanks for watching.
Good playthrough.
Oh, thank you!
Did you ever end up reaching out to Maddie?
I should, I should.
It's been so long since I've talked to her.
I just want to say hi.
That I love her.
She drew some really funny comics recently with Caitlin from
Final Fantasy VII.
Kate Sith for some of you guys.
I call him Caitlin because it's cuter.
Anyway, they're really funny.
Oh, it's you.
It's a meet now.
Thank you, everybody.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Have a good time zone.
I will see you when I see you next.
We're doing FNB tomorrow.
I'm so excited.
Watch out, out, out, out, out, out.
Eat out, out.
Bye.